Chaos Radio, der Computer Blumen bei Fritz jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat und so auch heute.
Ich bin mir ein bisschen schrecklich, dass ich das jetzt nicht so einfach machen kann. Ich bin mir ein bisschen schrecklich, dass ich das jetzt nicht so einfach machen kann.
Hohe Anforderungen werden heute an euch zuhause an den Radios gestellt, denn heute ist wirklich Multitasking angesagt. Fernsehen gucken, ohne Ton, Radio hören, Chaosradio nämlich bei Fritz. Vielleicht bei www.fritz.de slash Speakers dazu im Internet ein bisschen chatten mit den anderen Hörern und Hörerinnen und natürlich immer schön aufpassen. Wir sind nämlich heute wieder alle versammelt. Wer sind wir denn heute alle und funktionieren die Mikros?
Mal testen.
Das klingt schon wieder so ein bisschen nach Badezahler.
Das muss man wieder alles neu einstellen.
Ja, Tim ist anwesend.
Ja, Steini ist auch mal wieder da.
Und der Andreas.
Und ich wollte gleich erwähnen, dass es selbstverständlich auch den Chaos Classic Chat gibt. Tellnet auf www.ccc.de und da sitzt der Hans und der kümmert sich noch.
Sitzt der da wirklich?
Da davon gehen wir jetzt einfach mal aus.
Und als kleine Ankündigung, bevor die Mikros wieder richtig eingestellt sind, weil das ja immer hier im fliegenden Wechsel von Sendung zu Sendung geht, deswegen bleibt keine Zeit dazwischen, irgendwas groß vorzubereiten. Heute hier im Radio das Thema im allgemeinen Fernsehen.
Noch mal in kleinen Berichterstattungen. Ich glaube die Bulgarinnen haben jetzt ganz schön die Scheiße in der Hose.
Weil die fliegen nämlich sonst raus.
Das ist das Richtige hier. Ansonsten hier ist eher Geträngel im Mittelfeld und das Ganze ist nicht sehr schön.
2-0 für Spanien im Moment.
3-0, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Jetzt kommt ein kurzer Snapshot auf Nigeria und Paraguay, da steht es 1-1.
Wer interessiert das eigentlich?
Oh, und wie Herr Rufenbauer jetzt sagen würde, da ist ja wieder eine La-Ola.
Und dann werden wir euch heute in der Sendung noch erklären, warum Fernsehen scheiße ist, außer wenn Fußball werden ist. Chaosradio, der Computer Blumen, heute zum Thema Fernsehen.
Was hat denn das mit Computern zu tun?
Auch eine ganze Menge. Man braucht ja so ein Datensichtgerät, um sich auch auf den Computer die Bilder anzugucken. Außerdem ist das Fernsehen des deutschen liebstes Kind, der beim Bier trinkt, glaube ich, war das nicht so.
Außerdem sind wir alle mit Fernsehern als Datenmonitore groß geworden.
Und außerdem gibt es ja mittlerweile auch digitales Fernsehen und da braucht man einen Computer, um das zu gucken, ob der jetzt in so einer kleinen Kiste ist oder nicht, soll man da hingestellt.
Und dann gibt es ja auch Computerverschlüsselte, Sender und so. Da werden wir nachher auch noch ein paar Sätze zu verlieren.
Verlieren wir auch ein paar Sätze zum Thema Fußball-WM? Nein.
Nein? Gar nichts, ich gucke gerade hier ins Programm.
Fußball ist scheiße, Fernsehen ist auch scheiße.
Ich hab hier gleich Internet, dann kennen wir auch die aktuellen Ergebnisse wieder.
Gut, wir streiten uns jetzt noch ein bisschen über Fußball, aber ich würde sagen, wir fangen jetzt einfach mal an mit dem Fernsehen.
Tim, ich weiß was, was du nicht weißt.
3-1.
Können wir bitte den Fernseher hier mal ausmachen?
Heute geht es um schöner Fernsehen.
Genau.
Wir müssen auch ein bisschen Fernsehen gucken nebenbei. Nachher können wir ja noch ein bisschen darüber herziehen, wie sehr das Fernsehen uns alle verdürbt.
Wir können anfangen mit so ein bisschen Technik. Wir können erstmal erklären, wie geht das, ich verstehe nicht mal richtig, wie Radio funktioniert. Vielleicht könnt ihr es schaffen, mir zu erklären, wie Fernsehen funktioniert.
Sollen wir dir vorher noch erklären, wie Radio funktioniert?
Ach, das können wir nachher machen.
Gut, das fällt auch im Prinzip dabei ab. Ja, ich denke.
Dann schnallt euch schon mal an, das ist nämlich ganz schön kompliziert.
Fernsehen ist ja eigentlich eine tolle Erfindung. Und wie lange liegt denn das jetzt eigentlich zurück?
In den 20er Jahren. Manfred von der Antenne.
Ah, okay, jemand, nach dem sicherlich schon mal die eine oder andere Straße benannt worden ist.
Dann gibt es noch die Braunschirröhre, auch ein ganz wichtiger Begriff in dem Zusammenhang.
Warum?
Na ja, weil über die Braunschirröhre damals das Fernsehen überhaupt erst möglich wurde. Das heißt, irgendwie muss das Bild ja nun auch dargestellt werden, dass man es übertragen kann. Allein das reicht ja nicht.
Schön, dass ich gerade nichts sage, aber mein Computer ist eingefroren. Ich kläre mich für meistens solidarisch.
Es ist ein Macintosh.
Ich werde es beweisen, dass es ein Macintosh ist.
Wir machen mal den Bautschub.
Dafür werdet ihr zahlen.
Wollen wir mal beim Thema bleiben?
Es gibt ja verschiedene Fernsehsysteme, heißt das, dass die auch völlig anders technisch funktionieren?
Nee, nicht wirklich. Fangen wir vorne an.
Was ist denn eigentlich Fernsehen? Wie kommt denn das Bild über die Luft auf meine Scheibe? Warum ist die matt?
Warum die matt ist, das hat Fernsehen so an sich. Also das funktioniert im Prinzip so. Ursprünglich gab es da eine Röhre, die zeichnet da ein Bild auf. Wir machen das mal im Schnelldurchlauf. Du willst das genau haben, dann musst du es genau erklären.
Na gut, also das Problem, ein Bild auf den Bildschirm zu kriegen und es am besten auch noch irgendwie quer durch die Luft vorher zu schicken, hat einige Leute eine Weile lang beschäftigt. Die Lösung ist im Prinzip die, man nimmt eine Kathodenstrahlröhre, die in der Lage ist, einen Elektronenstrahl hinten eben aus dieser Kathode vorne auf eine Mattscheibe zu schmeißen. Da trifft dieser Strahl auf, auf phosphorisierende, irgendwie zum Leuchten bringende Teilchen, die dann halt leuchten, sodass man eben diesen Strahl einfach von links oben nach rechts in einer Zahl rüberschickt. Und überall, wo halt was leuchten soll, da wird halt kurz die Kathode angemacht und wo es nicht leuchten soll, wird es halt wieder ausgemacht.
Beziehungsweise hell und dunkel.
Genau, beziehungsweise hell und dunkel. Mit entsprechenden Braustufen abspielen wir dazwischen.
Wir unterhalten jetzt aber auch nicht darüber, bitte, wie dieses Bild überhaupt zum Bild wird, weil dann sitzt man nämlich morgen noch da.
Nein, das nicht. Aber was hier jetzt der interessante Punkt ist, und darauf werden wir ja noch mehrmals kommen, ist, dass das Bild eben zeilenweise aufgebaut wird und dass im Prinzip die Übertragungstechnik den Gegebenheiten der Wiedergabetechnik folgen musste. Das heißt, man hatte erst mal ein System, das überhaupt erst in der Lage war, Bilder so aufzubauen, und danach wurde eben dann auch die Übertragungstechnik gemacht. Das heißt, was von einem Funkturm ausgestrahlt wird, ist im Prinzip die direkte Handlungsanweisung für diese Röhre. Man muss von daher vom Zeitverhalten stimmen. Sprich, wenn die Röhre ganz unten angekommen ist und die letzte Zeile aufgebaut hat, dann muss sie wieder nach oben marschieren. Da das mit bestimmten technischen Begebenheiten so ist, dass es eben eine Weile dauert, bis der Strahl wieder oben ist, muss eben auch an der Stelle eine Pause gemacht werden. Also fassen wir einfach mal zusammen, was sich daraus ergibt. Wir haben einen zeilenweisen Bildaufbau. Das Bild besteht aus mehreren Zeilen. Genau genommen eben zwei Bilder. Und es gibt eine signifikante Pause zwischen der letzten Zeile und der ersten Zeile des nächsten Bildes, wo halt irgendwie Kurzhalt gemacht wird. So ist damals das Fernsehprogramm nackt überhaupt erst mal ins Leben gekommen, ohne irgendwelchen zusätzlichen Schnickschnack.
Und zwar wurde da damals auch nur Schwarz-Weiß übertragen. Das ist ein sogenanntes Luminanz, also ein Helligkeitssignal, das übertragen wurde. Und da dieses Helligkeitssignal, das musste ja nun auch irgendwo herkommen. Und das setzt sich so zusammen. Jede Farbe, also im Sinne von bunt, hat ja auch eine bestimmte Helligkeit. Und diese Helligkeit wird im Auge jetzt wieder, im Prinzip, also jetzt ein Rot, ein helles Rot hat eine bestimmte Helligkeit, ein dunkles Blau hat eine sehr dunkle Helligkeit. Und die haben ein bestimmtes Verhältnis zueinander. Das heißt, dieses Grau-Wert-Signal setzt sich zusammen. Da wird 0, 3 mal dem Rot-Helligkeitssignal genommen.
Jetzt musst du auch die ganze Vorhalle vorlesen.
Aber ich glaube, wir gehen hier ein bisschen zu schnell vor. Ich mein, zuerst waren ja einfach schwarz-weiß Kameras. Die haben das natürlich nicht machen müssen.
Ja doch, die mussten das auch machen.
Nein, die haben das nicht gemacht.
Das steckt da selbstverständlich drin, diese Theorie. Selbstverständlich steckt die da drin.
Nee, also die schwarz-weiß Kameras am Anfang haben einfach bloß eine Helligkeitsmessung gemacht und das Signal direkt übertragen. Das Problem war jetzt natürlich, wenn man Farbe übertragen wollte, dass man noch schwarz-weiß Fernseher hatte, die nur ein Helligkeitssignal haben wollten. Das heißt, dass man jetzt einen Weg finden musste, um dieses Farbsignal zu übertragen. Was man da gemacht hat, ist, außer den einzelnen drei Farben, Rot, Grün und Blau, die im Auge verwendet werden, die Helligkeit zu extrahieren und sozusagen die restlichen fehlenden Informationen noch zusätzlich drauf zu modulieren.
Das ist richtig.
Genau. Und der trinkreiche Nebeneffekt davon ist, dass man eben auch noch mit einem schwarz-weiß Fernseher farbausgestrahlte Programme mit angucken kann.
Das ist übrigens beim Radio ganz ähnlich. Da gab es nämlich zuerst die Mono-Aussendung und später kam Stereo dazu. Man wollte ja auch die Stereosendung mit Mono empfangen können. Was sie gemacht haben, ist ganz clever, die Summe des linken und des rechten Kanals zu übertragen und zusätzlich die Differenz der beiden Kanäle zu übertragen. Die Summe war das Monosignal. Das Differenzsignal, das getrennt übertragen wurde, reichte aus, um dann sozusagen aus der Summe plus der Differenz und minus der Differenz wieder links und rechts zu machen.
Und so ähnlich ist es aber beim Farbsignal, beim Fernsehen auch. Da wird nämlich auch nicht die Farbe zusätzlich übertragen, sondern nur die Differenz zum Luminanzsignal, nämlich die Differenz von dem Blauwert zum Luminanzsignal und dem Rotwert zum Luminanzsignal und der Grünwert ist da schon mit drin, sodass man also hier auch wieder tatsächlich mit dem Schwarz-Weiß-Fernseher auch ein Farbbild dekodieren kann, sich anschauen kann und die Graustufen ungefähr stimmen.
Das Stimme bei der ganzen Geschichte ist, dass die Farbinformation jetzt nicht nach einem einheitlichen Standard übertragen, sondern dass es erst die Amis gab, die NTSC eingeführt haben, was für Never-The-Same-Color steht bei einigen Leuten, weil die Qualität der Farbwiedergabe nicht besonders gut war.
Was heißt das eigentlich wirklich?
Ich hab auch noch so eine tolle Liste.
Okay, haben wir gelöst das Problem?
Na gut, in Europa gart es halt PAL, das steht für Probleme anderer Leute. Du weißt das besser Stein.
Face Alternate Line, das funktioniert dann noch ein bisschen. Das ist übrigens eine Weiterentwicklung des NTSC-Signals. Das funktioniert ungefähr so, dass die Farbe aus zwei aufeinander folgenden Zeilen sich gegenseitig optimiert. Das heißt, wenn bei der ersten Zeile die Farbe ein bisschen zu dunkel war, wird sie automatisch dadurch, dass die Phase um 180 Grad gedreht wird, bei der zweiten Zeile ein bisschen heller. Das heißt, wenn wir einen Phasenfehler insgesamt haben, dann gleicht er sich wieder aus und der Gesamteindruck von beiden Zeilen erscheint die Farbe wieder richtig. Und deswegen ist bei PAL die Farbe insgesamt zu einem wesentlich besseren Eindruck als bei NTSC oder CECAM.
Das klappt beim Radio nicht, weil wenn du da einen Phasendreher hast, hörst du gar nichts mehr.
Beim Radio ist das übrigens auch so, dass die beiden Kanäle Stereo, also der link und der rechte Kanal, um 180 Grad Chasen verschoben übertragen werden, und zwar genau aus dem selben Grund.
Also es ist nur so, ich hab das jetzt morgen zugehört.
Genau, Paraguay spürt mit 2 zu 1 und wir hören ein bisschen weiter Musik. Gleich gibt's einen Fritz Kurz Info und dann geht's weiter mit dem Fernsehen.
Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
Jetzt ist es nämlich 22.30 Uhr.
Grenzkontrollen vor dem morgigen Fußball-WM-Spiel Deutschland-Iran. Überprüft der Bundesgrenzschutz an allen Übergängen nach Frankreich, Autos und Züge auf gewaltbereite Hooligans. Es gab bereits mehrere Festnahmen und Waffenfunde. Abstimmung. Der Bundestag hat die Forderung von Bündnis 90 die Grünen nach einem Stopp des Transrapid-Projekts zurückgewiesen. Die Mehrheit der Abgeordneten sprach sich für den Bau der Magnetschwebebahn aus. Toleranzkonzept. Brandenburgs Regierung will der Ausländerfeindlichkeit im Land verstärkt entgegentreten. Mit einem Aktionsprogramm reagierte das Kabinett Stolper auf eine Umfrage, wonach jeder zweite Brandenburger Vorurteile gegen Ausländer hat. Unfall. Bei einem Schulbusunglück in der Nähe des sächsischen Ortes Pischdorf sind heute drei Kinder schwer und neun leicht verletzt worden. Der Busfahrer hatte ein haltendes Auto übersehen und war beim Bremsen in einen Straßengraben gerutscht.
Sport.
Bei der WM besiegte Frankreich Dänemark mit 2 zu 1. Saudi-Arabien und Südafrika trennten sich 2 zu 2. Für das Achtelfinale ist nach Frankreich nun auch Dänemark qualifiziert. Morgen nach Frühnebel meist heiter und trocken 23 bis 26 Grad.
Verkehr.
A9 Nürnberg Richtung Berlin. Sperrung der Anschlussstelle Niemäck wegen Bauarbeiten. Eine Umleitung ist ausgeschildert.
Das war Falk Zeke mit dem Fritz Kurzinfo.
Steht ein Fußball wirklich aus Polyurethan?
Was kostet eigentlich so ein Bundesligaspieler, falls man mal einen möchte?
Und wie hoch darf denn der Rasen beim WM-Finale sein? Tja, also ich weiß es auch nicht. Aber dafür weiß ich wer. Meister Soccer, der Experte für Fußballfragen aller Art. Beantwortet auch eure, wenn ihr ihn fragt. Jederzeit per Anrufbeantworter unter 0331 70 97 130 oder per Mail. Thor at orb.de Meister Soccer, beantwortet eure Fußballfragen immer Mittwochs und Freitags um 8.20 Uhr. Aber nur während der WM.
Ihr hört das Chaos Radio bei Fritz, den Computerblumen und Lennerts mit Woche Monate. Das Thema ist Fernsehen. Wir haben in der Essenheim schon ein bisschen angefangen, prinzipiell zu erklären, wie Fernsehen überhaupt funktioniert. Wie geht das überhaupt hier im Chaosradio? Gibt es da noch Sachen zu sagen?
Na, da gibt es bestimmt noch eine Menge zu klären. Zum Beispiel haben wir ja schon erklärt, wie aus einem Bild ein sozusagen analoges Signal wird und wie man aus diesem analogen Signal wieder ein Bild macht. Aber eine weitere wichtige Frage ist noch nicht geklärt, nämlich wie schickt man dieses analoges Signal durch die Luft? Und die Antwort lautet Modulation. Was da gemacht wird, also man hat ja erst ein analoges Signal mit einer Spannung, die sozusagen proportional zur Helligkeit auf dem Bildschirm ist. Und wenn man das jetzt übertragen will, beim Fernsehen wird FM verwendet, Frequenzmodulation genauso wie bei einem OKW Radio. Und das bedeutet, dass man einen sogenannten Carrier hat. Das ist die Frequenz, die man an seinem Tuner einstellt am Fernseher. Und jetzt wird abhängig von den Helligkeitsschwankungen diese Frequenz ein bisschen geändert. Das heißt, wenn ich ein sehr dunkles Bild habe, wird die Frequenz sehr wenig nach oben geschoben. Habe ich ein sehr helles Bild, einen sehr hellen Bild, dann wird die Frequenz sehr weit nach oben geschoben. Und auf der anderen Seite kann ich sozusagen, dadurch dass ich die Carrier-Frequenz wieder rausrechne, wieder das analoge, man nennt es, Basis beim Signal gewinnen.
Das wird natürlich nicht gerechnet. Das geht analog mit Filtern. Das sind dann Hochpassfilter, die im Prinzip nur das Signal, das da rauf moduliert ist, durchlassen und alles andere weglassen. Wenn man dieses Signal auf das, das drauf moduliert ist, sehr genau erkennt, kriegt man auch sehr genau die Information da runter. Und die braucht man dann eben, um das Bild auf dem Bildschirm darzustellen. Und da hatten wir es ja schon, das passiert in Zeilen. Es ist allerdings noch ein bisschen trickreicher, weil wenn man jetzt wirklich, so ein Bild besteht ja aus insgesamt 625 Zeilen. Bei PAL, genau. Bleiben wir mal kurz bei PAL. PAL ist die deutsche Norm. Bei diesem PAL-Signal werden aber nicht alle Zeilen auf dem Bildschirm dargestellt, sondern nur genau 578. Die anderen braucht man für ein paar andere Sachen, zum Beispiel Videotext, zum Beispiel besondere Informationen, Übertragung von Informationen zum Dekodieren von Premiere, Videokrypt und so fort und so fort.
Na im Wesentlichen natürlich auch erstmal VPS, dieses Steuersignal für Videorevideos, Programming.
Das sind aber alles Sachen, die konnte man zu dem Zeitpunkt, als man das entwickelt hat, noch nicht wissen, oder?
Nee, deswegen lässt man ja auch eine ganze Menge Zeilen weg.
Also am Anfang musste die Lücke halt einfach gelassen werden, weil eben alle an der Ausstrahlung beteiligten Geräte synchron, zeit-synchron arbeiten mussten. Die Sendeanstalt musste halt genau so takten, wie ein Fernseher das nette List darstellt. Da konnte halt keinerlei Asynchronizität reingebracht werden, wie das heute bei digitalen Systemen normal ist. Und dadurch entstand halt diese Lücke. Und man konnte eigentlich lange Zeit, wurde die halt einfach nur gar nicht genutzt. Also mir ist nicht bewusst, dass vor Videotext irgendeine Anwendung dafür gefunden worden ist. Und dann war halt mit Videotext das erste Mal die Überlegung, aha, da ist ja eh noch was frei. Wir hätten halt ganz gerne digitale Begleitinformationen. Und da war Videotext diese einfache Idee mit irgendwie Zeichen und halt so einfachen Blockklötzchen, dass man irgendwie auch noch so Fragmente malen kann, Farbe und so. War halt dann diese Begleitinformation dabei. Das ist nicht unbedingt immer dafür benutzt worden. Wir haben uns vorhin irgendwie noch gestritten, weil wir die Namen nicht so richtig wissen. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es Video-Dat ist. Vielleicht kann das ja einer mal im Chat sagen. Auf jeden Fall, bei ProSieben lief lange Zeit eben nicht Videotext, sondern da wurde eben Software übertragen über die Austastlöcke.
Daten halt, andere Daten.
Genau, soweit ich weiß, irgendwie PC-Software. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, ob das System was Video-Dat hieß oder ob das nicht das war, wo irgendwie mit dieser Bildeinblendung Daten übertragen wurden.
NDR Computer Club hatte das mal gemacht, oben links in der Ecke hell und dunkel Werte zu übertragen, die man mit einem Fotosensor abnehmen konnte und da jetzt wieder Daten rausmachen, Programme, Tools und so weiter.
War bestimmt sehr schnell.
Ja, war glaube ich. Wie die Dat, also ohne O. Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Chat-Fehler ist oder...
Ja, kann sein.
Wir mussten noch eine wichtige Sache erklären.
Ja, wollte ich eigentlich drauf raus, nämlich dieses Bild wird nicht komplett übertragen. Dazu reicht nämlich die Wandbreite bei diesem Signal nicht, sondern das wird in zwei Halbbildern übertragen. Das ist ganz, ganz wichtig. Und zwar ist es nicht so, dass 25-mal in der Sekunde, das ist ja die Bildwiederholfrequenz beim Fernsehen, ein ganzes Bild mit 578 Zeilen übertragen wird, sondern dass immer erst die erste Hälfte übertragen wird, die ungeraden Zahlen, also Zeilen, Zeile 1, Zeile 3, Zeile 5 usw. Und bei dem zweiten Durchgang wird die zweite Hälfte des Bildes, also Zeile 2, 4, 6 usw. übertragen. Das ganze Ding, also ein ganzes Bild nennt man auch ein Frame. Das brauchen wir nachher noch, wenn wir die anderen Sachen erklären. Und ein Halbbild ist ein Field. So, und das ist ganz wichtig, das zu verstehen, dass wir da wirklich zwei halbe Bilder haben. Das macht den Bildeindruck besser bei Bewegungen. Und wir haben jetzt also ein Pseudo 50-Hertz-Signal. Das macht also unheimlich viel aus bei schnellen Bewegungen und einfach ist auch eine bandbreite Frage. Es geht halt nicht schneller.
Also ich meine, es ist nicht deshalb irgendwie so gemacht worden, damit irgendwie die Bewegung besser aussehen soll, weil einfach damals die Trägheit der Röhrenführung eben noch so langsam war, dass man quasi gezwungen war, das so zu tun. Das heißt, man hat halt irgendwie ein Bild als zwei Bilder, die ineinander greifen, übertragen. Und die Phosphorschicht oben auf der Mattscheibe, die war halt irgendwie so nachleuchtend, dass sich das sozusagen auf der Scheibe erst vermischt zu einem Gesamtbild.
Genau, aber es ist schon so, man könnte natürlich auch das ganze Frame 25 Mal in der Sekunde übertragen. Dann hat man aber eben nur 25 Hertz und so hat man 50 Hertz. Es ist schon so, dass es technisch nicht geht, 50 Gansbilder zu übertragen. Das ist schon richtig. Aber man muss sehr gut unterscheiden, dass sie das auch 25 Gansbilder hätte übertragen können.
Genau, sie wollten 50 Hertz haben.
Sie wollten 50 Hertz, damit es nicht flimmert und flackert. Genau, das nennt man auch Interlaced, dieses Verfahren. Das gibt es beim Computer auch. Wenn du irgendwo lest, Monitor, so und so Frequenz, Interlaced, dann heißt das, es werden zweieinhalb Bilder übertragen.
Das heißt, es sieht scheiße aus.
Das heißt, beim Monitor sieht das scheiße aus, weil er nicht so lange nachleuchtet. Dann vermischt sich das nicht so gut und dann flimmert es halt.
Das ist eine typische Amiga-Optik, die man dann irgendwie bekommt.
Will man also nicht haben.
Bei Homecomputern.
Außerdem flimmern Fernseher auch.
Sorry, du hast mir nicht Bescheid gesagt.
Oh, ich hab's nicht gemerkt. Ich hab euch zugehört. Ich stellte sich natürlich jetzt die Frage, ab wann wird denn diese ganze Fernsehgeschichte interessant für Computerfreaks? Oder ab wann wird sie interessant für Leute, die sich mit Hacking beschäftigen?
Zunächst einmal ist Fernsehen eine Technologie wie jede andere auch. Von daher einfach Objekt der Begierde grundsätzlich. Das Zusammenlaufen von Fernsehen und Computern hat nicht wirklich früh angefangen. Also ich würde sagen, diese Datenübertragung im Videotext, das war eigentlich das erste, wo diese Technologien wirklich zusammengeführt wurden, wo also ein Computer selber angefangen hat, das übertragende Fernsehsignal auszuwerten. Dann natürlich Teletext, also Videotext-Decoder. Videotext heißt es ja eigentlich nur bei ARD und ZDF. Meine eigentliche Bezeichnung ist Teletext. Da gibt es so diverse Software, die da angeboten wird und natürlich auch Hardware, also spezielle TV-Karten, die einerseits in der Lage sind, ein Fernsehbild anzuzeigen. Und die Software kraft sich dann eben auch noch das Teletext-Signal rauszuhören, das getrennt anzeigen. Dann kann man halt auf seinem Computer Fernsehen gucken. Das ist sowieso eigentlich durchaus eine berechtigte Forderung, dass irgendwie ein Computer, den man heute für mehrere tausend Mark kauft, dass eigentlich auch noch ein Fernseher mit drin ist, weil die Technik ist nicht teuer, um das zu machen. Man muss es halt bloß noch mit reinbauen. Und der nächste Schritt ist natürlich der, also die Frage, also die Computer wenden sich eigentlich gar nicht so sehr dem Fernsehen zu, sondern jetzt ist es eigentlich so, dass das Fernsehen sich eher den Computern zuwendet. Denn man hat halt gesehen, dass das zwar wunderbar funktioniert mit dem Palen, dem Seekam, aber dass eigentlich die Bandbreiten, die Frequenz bandbreiten Verschwendungen durch analoge Übertragung immens ist. Dass man vor allem heutzutage zweierlei möchte, man möchte mehr Kanäle übertragen, zweitens möchte man mehr Begleitinformation übertragen und man möchte das vor allem in einer besseren Qualität. Also man möchte Bild und Ton und Format auf einen neueren Standard bringen, gibt es so diverse Schlagworte. Man fing dann erstmal an bei den Fernsehern rumzuschrauben, die dann irgendwie die Bilder zwischengespeichert haben und mit 100 Hertz auf dem Bildschirm gebracht haben.
100 Hertz Technik, genau.
Das hat schon mal den Vorteil, dass dadurch, dass das Bild doppelt so schnell aufgebaut wird, zumindest das Flimmern des Gerätes selber schon mal wegfällt. Dadurch wird natürlich die eigentliche Bildinformation nicht verbessert. Aber die Darstellung des Bildes ist halt sehr viel besser.
Sollten wir kurz erklären. Da werden also beide Fields, wir hatten das gerade, zwei Halbbilder im Fernsehgerät gespeichert, in einem digitalen Buffer, in einem Speicher. Und werden dann einfach 100 Mal in der Sekunde auf den Bildschirm gebracht. Als Vollbild, als komplettes Frame. Das führt nicht dazu, dass wir jetzt mehr Information haben, dass wir mehr Bewegung oder so etwas haben, dass es fließender geht, aber es führt dazu, dass das Bild an solches nicht mehr so sehr flimmert.
Und es auch nicht mehr so nachleuchtet, weil der Computer im Fernseher das digital zwischenspeichert und die Zwischenspeicherung nicht mehr in der Phosphorschicht gemacht werden muss.
Genau, und das macht schlichtweg ein viel, viel, viel besseres Bild. Man kann dann auch digitale Farbkorrekturen da noch anbringen, das bringt auch noch mal ein bisschen was.
Ja, also ein besseres Bild.
Ja, und dann können sie hinter euch flimmert kommen, weil es steht 3 zu 1 für Parguay.
Echt? Jo, die machen sie fertig.
Gut, wir hatten, glaube ich, noch mehr.
franz98.com, jetzt müssen wir die Tabellen holen.
Geh weg! Sollten wir vielleicht das kurze Schwenk noch machen auf das digitale Fernsehen, das ist nämlich im Prinzip die Neuentwicklung des Fernsehens.
Wir sind ja noch zu den Ehrläutern der deutschen Industrie.
Also 16 zu 9 war ja dann das andere Schlagwort. Alle wollten vor allem besseres Fernsehen haben, aber vor allem gab es halt das große Interesse der Filmindustrie, dass das Fernsehformat an sich sich ändert. Weil heutzutage ist halt das Seitenverhältnis 4 zu 3, was ja ganz nett ist für Tagesschau, aber die Optik des Menschen geht halt mehr in die Breite als in die Höhe und so sind ja auch alle Hollywood-Filme irgendwie gemacht. Also früher wurden sie in 16 zu 9 gemacht, dann Cinemascope, das glaube ich mittlerweile schon fast Standard 20 zu 9, ich weiß es nicht genau. Und zumindest wollten sie eben auf dieses 16 zu 9 Bildformat gehen. Das war also auch ein Grund, darüber nachzudenken, die Technik zu erweitern, neben diesen Bandbreitengeschichten und der Qualitätsverbesserung. Und dann haben sie sich alle hingesetzt und überlegt, wie machen wir denn das? Und Deutschland war ja dann der Meinung, dass sie irgendwie ja Fernseh sowieso erfunden haben, müssen sie den nächsten Schritt dann auch gleich machen. Und dann kam da was raus. Erstmal kam ein Buzzword dabei raus. Das hieß HDTV. Das war sozusagen die Summe, die Terminologie für die Summe aller Wünsche. Wir wollen besser Fernsehen gucken können.
Hieß das jetzt High Definition oder High Density? Wie war es denn?
Soweit ich weiß, High Definition.
High Definition TV.
Ich glaub, das hieß High Density.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau. Wenn das jemand weiß, möge er das mal im Chat schreiben.
Oder was auch nicht so wichtig ist. Auf jeden Fall wollten sie halt tolles Hans-Mein-Definition, ich glaube auch Definition. Die Wege dahin waren dann halt unterschiedlich. Also allen war klar, dass man sozusagen auch digitalisieren muss. Was halt irgendwie in Europa rübergekommen ist von digital ist, das CD ja toller klingt als Schallplatte. Das gängige Vorurteil. Deswegen hat man sich eigentlich erstmal für eine Fernsehnorm entschieden, von der sie glaubten, dass sie sie früher am Markt etablieren könnten, die eben nur teilweise Verbesserungen bringt. Erstens das neue Format, 16 zu 9. Zweitens digitalen Ton. Aber eben nach wie vor eine analoge Bildübertragung.
Und das war der Unterschied, die Komponenten des Bildes, also die Helligkeit und die Farbinformation werden nicht mehr gleichzeitig übertragen, sondern nacheinander und das gibt dann im Empfänger sozusagen eine digitale Zwischenspeicherung, wo die drei Komponenten nacheinander gespeichert und dann gemeinsam dargestellt werden.
Ah, sodass die Verfälschung nicht mehr so groß sein konnte. Ok, also ein durch digitale Hilfe, besser übertragendes analoges Signal, was aber nichts daran geändert hat, dass die Bandbreite, die dafür benötigt wurde, immer noch relativ hoch war.
Ja, sogar noch massiv gestiegen ist, weil man eben auch mehr Bildpunkte brauchte, weil dieses 16 auf 9 Format natürlich nur gut aussieht, wenn man auch mehr Bildpunkte hat, wenn man sich überlegt, die paar Punkte pro Zeile, die wir heute haben, 768 sind es glaube ich pro Zeile, reicht natürlich für so einen Breitbandfernsehen überhaupt nicht aus. Musste also massiv nach oben, die Bandbreite steigt dadurch und man hat wieder eigentlich nichts Besonderes gewonnen, außer eine Krücke, um aus analogen Fernsehen jetzt doch noch ein gutes Bild rauszuholen.
Genau, das hat sich natürlich nicht durchgesetzt, weil die Leute keinen neuen Fernseher kaufen wollten, keinen neuen Satrisierer und so weiter.
Die kostet ja auch heute noch 5.000 bis 7.000 Mark, das hat sich also nie irgendwie...
Naja, es gab ja auch die 2-Mark im 4 zu 3-Format, das sich genauso wenig durchgesetzt hat.
Stimmt, war auch zu teuer. Warum was kaufen, was eigentlich schon irgendwie geht? Also der Bedarf der Leidensdruck war scheinbar nicht besonders groß.
Naja, bei manchen war der Leidensdruck glaube ich schon groß genug, weil es ja nicht so, dass sich keiner irgendwie die 2-Mark gekauft hätte, sondern eben nur verdammt wenige.
Naja, aber die Leute, die sich die 2-Mark gekauft haben, haben das getan, weil es einige Sender gab, die nur mit die 2-Mark gesendet haben, und das ist schon fast beim Thema der Sendung, weil es nämlich das Eurogroup-Verfahren gab und die Sender mit Eurogroup verschlüsselt waren und man sich sowieso so ein Decoder hinstellen muss, da war dann halt auch die 2-Mark drin.
Genau, und da gab es dann noch das erste Mal das, was es bei AD und ZDF nicht gab, nämlich Pornos. Und tolle Spielfilme. Und zwar ohne Werbung. Bei den Bestellern immer wieder fest, wenn irgendetwas die Computertechnologie wirklich nach vorne bringt auf dem Markt, dann sind es Pornos. Also jede Technik, die irgendwie Pornotechnologie in der Lage ist, irgendwie zum Kunden zu bringen, die hat halt schon mal große Vorteile.
Ganz egal, wie schlecht es ist.
Da sind wir aber jetzt eigentlich schon fast zu weit, weil warum Fernsehen scheiße ist, da wollten wir uns erst am Ende drüber unterhalten.
Ach, sind wir jetzt schon da, wo es scheiße ist? Also um es kurz zu machen, die ZweiMark hat halt irgendwie einen Nischenmarkt besetzen können. Richtig? So nicht? Also weil dadurch, dass eben auch diese digitale Begleitinformation in größerem Umfang schon drin war, war es sehr viel einfacher, eine Verschlüsselungstechnologie mit in dieses System einfließen zu lassen. Was nicht heißt, dass es nicht für die normalen Analogen auch ging. Also wir stehen jetzt sozusagen auf einem Zeitlauf, wie wir das jetzt erzählen, an der Stelle, wo eben die Privatisierung des Fernsehens und irgendwie diese zunehmende Mehrkanaligkeit in Europa auch Fuß gefasst hat. So von den USA will ich jetzt gar nicht reden, da weiß ich auch nicht so viel drüber. Aber in Deutschland ging es halt los mit den Satelliten, also in Europa ging es halt los mit den Satelliten. Der erste Astra, wie sie alle hießen, kam halt hoch. Erst mal Eutelsat.
Ja, Eutelsat, als erstes kam Astra, dann kam der zweite Astra, dann kam Copernicus.
Dann kam der dritte, vierte, fünfte Astra.
Und jetzt kommt irgendwann der siebte und acht. Also Fernsehen ist auch in Europa wirklich ein großer Markt geworden und damit steigt natürlich auch massiv das Interesse, diesen Markt zu befriedigen und dafür eben auch Geld zu bekommen, weil irgendwie wollen die ja Geld verdienen mit dem Kram. So, und da sind wir denke ich jetzt schon beim Thema, wollen wir erst digital machen oder wollen wir erst...
Ach, wir machen eine kurze Pause und dann machen wir digital. Ist zu Ende da? 3 1 Paragraph? Ich weiß, es steht 6-1 für Spanien gegen Bulgarien, ich glaub's nicht.
Genau, Tim mach mal diesen Scheiß-Bussballkran hier weg bitte.
Das nervt.
Der sabbelt eh nur Mist.
Ich hab überhaupt keinen einzigen Kommentator in der was ordentliches ist, außer Günther Netzer.
Wie bitte?
Günther Netzer als den besten Scheiß. Können wir jetzt mal ein Thema machen.
Günther Netzer steht da immer da und findet alles Scheiße.
Also ich hab nicht so einen schlimmen Eindruck bei ihm.
Machen wir mal digital Fernsehen, würde ich sagen.
Genau.
Digitales Fernsehen. Warum und wie geht das? So, warum ist ganz einfach. Erstens, wenn was digital ist, dann sind das Einsen und Nullen oder nicht Halbe oder Dreiviertelste, sondern dann geht das oder es geht nicht. Und wenn es geht, geht es richtig gut. Ist klar, da geht dann nicht verloren. Und das Bild ist super brillant, schön bunt und alles. Und zum anderen kann man digitale Information hervorragend komprimieren. Das heißt, man kriegt einfach mehr Kanäle pro Bandbreite zum Kunden. Und das ist natürlich für die Anbieter ganz wichtig.
Wobei sich diese Erkenntnis mit dem, dass man es toll komprimieren kann, auch erst in den letzten Jahren wirklich durchgesetzt hat. Weil am Anfang dachten sie, das dauert eh alles noch 30 Jahre, bis die Computertechnik soweit ist, mit diesen Datenmengen klarzukommen.
Das ist auch relativ schwierig, Videos zu komprimieren und zu dekomprimieren. Das sind unglaubliche Datenmengen, die da anfallen. So ein normales, unkomprimiertes digitales Fernsehsignal, wie es ja schon früher im digitalen Studio benutzt wurde, hat 270 Megabit pro Sekunde. Wenn man das einfach ohne Kompressionen versucht rauszuschicken, braucht man die 10- 12- 14-fache Bandbreite vom normalen Fernsehen. Es gibt da aber die Motion Pictures Expert Group. Bekannt ist das Kürze von denen, das ist MPEG, die sich irgendwann hingesetzt haben und sich ein Standard zur Bildkompression ausgedacht haben. Das war so ein Komitee, das aus mehreren hundert Leuten bestand, von verschiedenen Firmen, die sich zusammengesetzt haben.
Wohlgemerkt bewegt Bildkompression. Weil du gerade gesagt hast, Bildkompression, das geht dabei um Bewegbilder. Ja, ist ein deutlicher Unterschied zum Bild.
Wobei, was sie da machen bei MPEG ist, erstmal im ersten Schritt dasselbe wie bei JPEG. JPEG ist ja Einzelbildkompression und da wird sozusagen das, also erstmal wird das Bild gesampelt, das heißt das Analogsignal wird abgetastet, dann wird das in den Frequenzraum transformiert, das heißt, es wird geguckt aus welchen Frequenzen setzt sich das zusammen, also gleichförmige Flächen haben eine sehr niedrige Frequenz, abwechselnde schwarze und weiße Streifen haben eine sehr hohe Frequenz. Man kann das sozusagen in so eine Frequenzdarstellung umwandeln. Das Schöne an der Frequenzdarstellung ist, dass da meistens relativ viele Werte null sind, also fast null sind, die kann man dann gleich ganz auf null setzen. Wenn man das zurück transformiert, sieht das Bild dann sehr ähnlich aus. Das ist so wie JPEG funktioniert. Und bei MPEG ist es fast dasselbe, nur dass sie da zusätzlich noch die Differenz zwischen zwei Bildern berücksichtigen. Sie gucken sich ein Bild an und das nächste Bild wird dann aus kleinen Stücken des Bildes davor zusammengesetzt und es wird bis noch die Differenz dazu gespeichert.
Genau, also nochmal ganz einfach erklärt. JPEG basiert darauf, dass in einem Bild die Unterschiede zwischen den Bildpunkten zueinander meistens nicht sehr groß sind. Das heißt benachbarte Punkte sind sich sehr ähnlich. Bei MPEG kommt zusätzlich dazu, dass zwei aufeinander folgende Bilder eines Videofilmens komplett sich auch sehr ähnlich sind. Das wird dann in kleinen Rechtecken betrachtet und nur noch die Differenz aufgehoben. Damit kriegt man eine Kompressionsfaktor von...
Also das kommt drauf an, wie man es rechnet. Wenn man die 270 Megabit vom digitalen Videostudio rechnet, dann kommt man auf 1 zu 100. Das ist natürlich völlig unrealistisch, weil auch die Austauschlücke mit Samplen alles mit 10 Bit. In der Realität ist es so, dass man ungefähr auf eine Kompression von 1 zu 20 kommt.
Ja, so in etwa. Das hängt natürlich auch von der Bildqualität ab, die man hinterher erwartet.
Das ist richtig. Man kann das relativ beliebig skalieren. Man gibt bei MPEG eine Bandbreite vor, das heißt, wie viel Bit pro Sekunde man zur Verfügung hat. Und die Encoder versuchen dann die bestmögliche Bildqualität für die zur Verfügung stehende Bandbreite rauszuholen.
Und wenn die zu niedrig ist, sieht es halt scheiße aus. Und wenn die hoch genug ist, sieht das toll aus. So, das war jetzt im Wesentlichen MPEG 1. Es gibt ja eine Neuentwicklung davon.
Es gibt MPEG 2. Der Unterschied ist der MPEG 1 ist nur für halbe Paarlauflösung definiert. Das ist das Common Intermediate Format CIF mit 300 x 200 Pixel ungefähr. Und das ist das, was zum Beispiel auf den Video CDs drauf ist. Genau.
150 Kilo Byte pro Sekunde kommen da runter.
Genau, da kommt der Datenstrom, der auch von einer normalen Audio CD runterkommt. Und bei MPEG 2 wollten sie ursprünglich ein neues Verfahren entwickeln. Sie haben dann festgestellt, dass man MPEG 1 einfach auch mit größeren Bildgrößen, mit anderen Bildwiederholraten fahren kann. Vor allen Dingen kann man mit MPEG 2 das jetzt auch auf Interlace-Bilder anwenden. Das heißt, MPEG 1 arbeitet immer mit Vollbildern. 25 Vollbilder pro Sekunde. Währenddessen wir bei Fernsehen immer diese Field-Geschichte haben, also jeweils zwei Halbbilder. Und MPEG 2 berücksichtigt die Halbbilder. Und MPEG 2 beinhaltet auch eine verbesserte Audiokodierung, die mehr als zwei Audiokanäle unterstützt. Das heißt, man kann damit dann auch Surround-Sound übertragen und so weiter.
Oder Filme in verschiedenen Sprachen und so weiter.
Was auch wichtig ist bei MPEG 2, ist, dass MPEG 1 dafür designed war, dass man eine fehlerlose Übertragung hat. von einer CD gelesen. MPEG 2 hat einen sogenannten Transportstream. Das sind Pakete identischer Größe. Und wenn Pakete zwischendrin verloren gehen, dann macht das nichts. Dann kann das Bild trotzdem hinterher weiter dekodiert werden. Ist also geeignet, dafür eine Fernsehübertragung zu machen, wenn man ja immer mal Störungen hat.
Ich muss sagen, aber da regnet's, da geht was verschütt. Da wird das Bild an der Stelle kurz schlecht, aber das ist am nächsten Feature ja okay.
Also bei MPEG ist es jetzt so, dass wir über einen Transponder beim Satelliten jetzt nicht nur einen Kanal übertragen können, sondern mehrere Kanäle. Da wo früher ein analoger Fernsehkanal war, hat man heute einen digitalen Kanal von 34 Megabit pro Sekunde. Und über diesen Kanal kann man jetzt mehrere Fernsehkanäle übertragen. Die werden gemultiplexed, sagt man. Und abhängig davon, wie sehr sich die Bildinformation im Bild gerade verändert, braucht man für MPEG eine höhere oder eine geringere Bandrate. In dem Buch, den ich habe, gibt es so eine schöne kurze Geschichte. Mann und Frau schauen sich tief in die Augen. Rechts ist der Gramm der benötigten Bandbreite, die sehr gering ist. Und dann die Explosion im Hintergrund. Und dann wird die Bitrate, die gebraucht wird, entsprechend größer. Und dann liegen sie sich in den Arm und dann geht die Bitrate wieder zurück. Und es ist jetzt also möglich, in diesen 34 Megabit pro Sekunde so ungefähr sechs bis acht Fernsehkanäle unterzubringen. Und je nachdem, welcher Kanal gerade mehr Bandbreite benötigt, kriegt er halt ein bisschen mehr, der andere ein bisschen weniger und so weiter und so fort. Man kann das Ganze so weit treiben, wie man möchte. Wie gesagt, die Bitrate ist variabel. Man kann bis zu zwölf Kanäle übertragen. Die haben dann aber gerade noch so VHS Qualität. Wenn man sechs Kanäle pro Transponder hat, also dann ungefähr fünf bis sechs Megabit pro Fernsehkanal, dann hat man ungefähr das, was man heute an Broadcast Qualität hat.
Und die Untergrenze liegt so bei zwei Megabit, was man noch sehen möchte. Was man sich also anschauen kann. Das ist, wie gesagt, VHS, so Videokassetten mäßig.
Da kommen wir dann natürlich langsam jetzt in das Zeitalter, wo halt auch der Unterschied zwischen der Ausstrahlung und den Videos, die auf der CD sind, nicht mehr besonders groß ist, nicht? Also die Video-CD hat das ja im Prinzip schon irgendwie vorgemacht, was ich ja vorhin erwähnt, MPEG-1-Videos.
Und auf der DVD ist jetzt MPEG-2 drauf. Und das ist genau derselbe Bitstrom, der auch beim DVB, beim Digital Video Broadcast, also im Digital Fernsehen verwendet wird. Im Grunde genommen also genau dieselben Daten, nur dass sie einmal von der DVD kommen, das andere mal vom Satelliten.
Also DVB spezifiziert jetzt glaube ich nur die terrestrische Ausstrahlung.
Nee, DVB spezifiziert digitales Fernsehen. Das verteilt sich dann in terrestrische Ausstrahlung, Ausstrahlung über Satellit und Ausstrahlung über Kabelnetze, wo jeweils verschiedene Modulationsverfahren verwendet werden. Wo aber dann hinterher der Content, der übertragen wird, dasselbe ist. Es ist nämlich tatsächlich einfach NPEG-2.
Genau, also man kann das, was da vom digitalen Fernsehsatelliten runterkommt, kann man eigentlich auf eine DVD raufbrennen, diesen Datenstrom und kann das dann direkt auch anschauen. Das ist also wirklich das gleiche Format. Auch wenn da viele Leute was anderes behaupten.
Naja, das bringt uns jetzt zu unserem zweiten großen Thema, nämlich die Verschlüsselung. Also es gibt halt ein größeres Interesse daran, Signale auch verschlüsselt auszusenden, damit halt nicht immer so pauschal abgerechnet wird, wie das hier komischerweise immer noch irgendwie funktioniert angeblich, aber über kurz oder lang läuft es halt aufs direktbezahlen, direkt abonnieren hinaus. Genau, und das ist doch ein......dass Fernsehen und Zeitungen im Prinzip genauso konsumiert wird. Und da gibt es halt verschiedene Verfahren, die sich da durchgesetzt haben. Die ersten, die verschlüsselt gesendet haben, waren Sky.
Nein, das waren......es gab früher noch andere Kanäle, die mittlerweile so ein bisschen eine Bedeutung verloren haben. Ja, Teleclub zum Beispiel und noch ein paar andere, die analoge Scramding-Verfahren verwendet haben. Das heißt, da war ein rein analoges Signal. Alles, was sie gemacht haben, war, dieses Signal ein bisschen abzufälschen. Also zum Beispiel mit der Position des Zeilenrücklaufsignals zu spielen und das Audio zu invertieren oder das Bild zu invertieren und so weiter und so fort. Das hat aber alles nicht viel getaugt, weil sozusagen der Decoder nicht personalisiert war. Das heißt, man konnte den Decoder nehmen und nachbauen und dann konnte man auch mit dem Nachbau gucken. Man konnte vor allem den Decoder nicht zentral abschalten, aber wenn man den Decoder einmal hatte, konnte man dann bis an seinen Lebensende den Kanal gucken.
Na ja, nur davon abgesehen, dass es den Kanal nicht so lange gab.
Was gab es das auch noch?
Na ja, sehr lange gab es das nicht, das war sehr schnell gehackt.
Ja, es gab verschiedene Verfahren, die alle relativ schnell gehackt wurden.
Und danach wurde also klar, man braucht hier etwas, was besser funktioniert.
Und ich glaube diese Personalisierungsgeschichte war auch ein wesentlicher Grund dafür, dass sich die Dinger nicht durchgesetzt haben. Weil man ja im Prinzip von jedem einzelnen Kohle haben will. Wenn das Gerät allein schon decodieren kann, ist es mit Nachbauten dann auch schon relativ schnell.
Und das andere Problem ist, dass die Filmrechte natürlich auch immer viel Geld kosten. Und zwar kosten sie natürlich umso mehr, je weiter sie auch ausgestrahlt werden sollen. Das heißt, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel ein Sender wie Sky europaweit senden wollte, wäre das sehr viel teurer, als wenn sie sagen, sie senden nur für den britischen Raum. Insofern ist das Verschlüsselung auch ein Thema, um diesen Ausstrahlungsrange kleiner zu halten. Wir kriegen dann auch die Rechte billiger. Dafür müssen sie aber dem Anbieter auch garantieren können, dass wirklich nur die Leute im britischen Raum das gucken können. Ist ja klar. Und deswegen hat man stärkere Verschlüsselungen eingeführt.
Erstmal die Adressierung der einzelnen Geräte. Das war sozusagen der entscheidende Schritt dabei. Da kommt auch schon die erste Digitalkomponente rein, wenn man nicht digital mit dem Gerät reden musste, ihm sagen musste, jetzt musst du dich einschalten, jetzt musst du dich ausschalten. Konkret hat es die Form von Chipkarten angenommen. Das heißt, man hat da ein Decoder zu stehen. Man schiebt in den Decoder seine Chipkarte. Und auf der Chipkarte steht eine Nummer drauf. Und die kann man sich dann freischalten lassen. Oder die wird dann auch wieder abgeschaltet, wenn man nicht bezahlt.
So ist das.
So, der nächste Schritt war dann, dass man jetzt auch verhindern muss, dass man sowas irgendwie nachbaut. Oder mit anderen Hilfsmitteln das guckt. Sodass also das rohe Bild, das man da kriegt, halt wirklich so scheiße aussieht, dass man das nicht gucken kann. So, das ist ja Verschlüsselung. Ich muss verhindern, dass Unbefugte das schauen. Da wurde dann irgendwann Videokrypt eingeführt. Ein Verschlüsselungsstandard, relativ einfacher Art, der aber bis heute noch aktuell ist. Und zum Beispiel von Sky, diesen ganzen Sky-Kanälen, UK Gold und so weiter, Sky Movies verwendet wird. Dieses Verfahren ist sehr einfach. Die machen folgendes. Die nehmen jede Bildzeile eines Fields und zerhacken die irgendwo in der Mitte an einer beliebigen Stelle in dieser Zeile und vertauschen diese beiden Hälften. Das heißt also, dass jede Zeile irgendwie hinterher anders zusammengesetzt bei mir ankommt.
Bei welchem Verfahren bist du jetzt gerade?
Videokrypt, sagt ich gerade, Videokrypt 1. Also das ursprüngliche Videokrypt-Verfahren von Sky. Das funktioniert eben so, dass die Zeile immer zerhackt und vertauscht wird. Das wird für jede Zeile anders getan an einer anderen Stelle. Was dabei herauskommt, ist ein riesengroßes Durcheinander von zerhackten Zeilen, die man hinterher nicht mehr anschauen kann. Es ist nun sehr einfach, das wieder zu dekodieren. Ich muss einfach jede Zeile, die irgendwie zerhackt wurde, in meinen Decoder, in einen Speicher tun. Der Speicher muss auch eben nur so groß sein, dass da eine Zeile nicht das ganze Bild reinpasst. Das ist schön billig. Dann wird eine Information digital übertragen in der Austastlücke, von der wir vorhin schon sprachen, parallel zu diesen Videotextzeugs. Das ist ein Startwert, ein Seed, also eine Saat, sagt man. Die sät man und da wächst dann was draus. Ein Startwert für einen Pseudo Random Number Generator. Also ein Algorithmus, der viele Zahlen generiert, die irgendwie sehr unterschiedlich sind. Und zwar beginnt mit einer bestimmten. So, und diese Zahl, die ist natürlich verschlüsselt übertragen. In dieser Austastlücke wird von der Chipkarte entschlüsselt. Da kommt dieser Startwert, dieser Seed raus. Und dieser Seed generiert jetzt 256 Zahlen, mal Anzahl der Zeilen. Und dieser Wert ist ein bisschen knifflig. Da kommen also jetzt 256 mal 288 Zahlen raus. Und diese Zahl ist jeweils zwischen 0 und 768. Nämlich genau der Bruchpunkt, an dem die Zahlen vertauscht sind. So, der Decoder...
Ist klar soweit.
Ist eigentlich ganz einfach. Was der Decoder macht, er nimmt diese Zahl, vertauscht die Zeile wieder und gibt sie an den Tuner, um das Videobild darzustellen. Sodass hinterher aufgrund von einer einfachen Zahl, eine Zahl, die glaube ich 64 oder 128 Bit lang ist, verschlüsselt tatsächlich so viele Informationen rauskommen, um all diese Zeilen von diesen 256 Halbbildern wieder richtig sortiert werden können. So, und das ist im Wesentlichen das Verfahren. Das heißt, sehr wenig Daten müssen zum Kunden übertragen werden. Das Gerät kann sehr, sehr einfach sein. Und trotzdem entsteht dabei wieder das vollständig dekodierte Bild zum Angucken.
Das heißt, wenn ich es mal so ein bisschen zusammenfassen darf, im Kern basiert Videocrypt darauf, dass immer eine Zeile für sich verschlüsselt wird. Die Verschlüsselung basiert darauf, dass eigentlich nur mit dem gesamten Bild eine einzige Zahl zusätzlich noch mit übertragen wird digital, die der Decoder dann...
Das ist pro Bild noch pro 256 Bilder.
Pro 256?
Pro 256 Halbbilder. Also alle zweieinhalb Sekunden werden 128 Bilder übertragen.
Okay. Und diese Zahl fließt in den Decoder ein. Beziehungsweise geht ja dann nicht in den eigentlichen Satellitendecoder, also nicht in den eigentlichen Receiver, sondern eben in diese Chipkarte, die an der Seite noch mit reingesteckt ist, auf der ein Prozessor ist und die diese Zahl entgegennimmt. Und aufgrund dieser Zahl, eine andere Zahl, rausspuckt nämlich eine Zufallszahl. Das heißt, der Sender und diese Smartcard, die die eigentliche Entschlüsselung besorgt, synchronisieren sich eben nur über diese Zahl.
Wenn man die Smartcard macht, nicht die eigentliche Verschlüsselung. Die eigentliche Verschlüsselung steckt in dem Decoder drin. Aber die Smartcard entschlüsselt sozusagen den Startwert, damit man zweieinhalb Sekunden lang das Bild entschlüsseln kann.
Also die liefert nur den Wert und der Decoder ist im Receiver drin. Alles klar, verstehe.
Und da ist ein ROM drin, da ist ein Programm drin, das wird abgearbeitet. Das ist übrigens auch schon reichlich bekannt. Das hat mal jemand disassembliert, den kennt man. Diesen Algorithmus, das hilft nur nichts, jedenfalls nicht besonders viel, weil man ja nicht weiß, wie man aus dem verschlüsselten Startwert, den entschlüsselten Startwert macht, der ist nämlich in der Chipkarte drin.
Jetzt kommen wir aber auch schon zu dem Punkt, wo man das System angreifen kann. Das Interessante ist natürlich, dass alle denselben Startwert kriegen müssen. Was man also machen kann, ist, sich zwei Decoder hinzustellen, dann nimmt man sich zwei Drähte und legt einmal die Datenleitung von der Chipkarte in den zweiten Decoder und die Reset-Leitung in den zweiten Decoder. Dann schalten wir beide Decoder ein, dann kann man auf beiden mit einer Chipkarte gucken, funktioniert heute noch.
Genau. Ist natürlich nicht so prickelnd, weil das Kabel entweder sehr lang sein muss oder man muss nebeneinander sitzen.
Na ja, genau genommen kann das Kabel auch Internet heißen, aber dazu kommen wir ja später.
Das sind dann die Feinheiten des Systems. Wieso kommen wir da später zu? Können wir gleich machen, passt doch nicht, oder?
Das ist die VCL-Geschichte, ne?
Das war ja ein bisschen historisch vorgesehen.
Wir waren ja gerade bei Videocrypt 1. Das ist ja eigentlich ein Format, das bei uns am Breiten nicht verwendet wird.
Das ist ein rein britisches Format. Also das wird für den britischen Raum verwendet von Sky usw. usw. Das kommt natürlich über Astra und ist damit auch in ganz Europa zu empfangen. Aber man kann das ordnungsgemäß nur abonnieren, indem man Britte ist und dort eben dafür bezahlt, dass man das darf. Als Deutscher, als Französer oder sowas kann man das nicht abonnieren.
Also wenn man da keinen Wohnsitz hat.
Genau.
Ja, analog zur Videocrypt 1 gibt es auch noch Videocrypt 2, die das im Wesentlichen genau dasselbe ist und das halt außerhalb von Europa verwendet wird. So zum Beispiel MTV wird in Videocrypt 2 übertragen und Filmnet, ein sehr gärter Kanal und die anderen auch noch.
Wobei eigentlich die, es ist nicht so ausgebreitet, diese Videocrypt 2 gibt es eigentlich. Wird kaum verwendet.
Na ja, eine Handvoll Kanäle halt.
Ja, das ist nicht so. Und das ist dasselbe Verfahren, also wenn man das eine angreifen kann, kann man das andere auch angreifen.
Also bei Videocrypt 2 gibt es ja auch schon verschiedene Hacklösungen. Die werden ja auch irgendwie...
Wollen wir nicht erstmal die Verschlüsselungsverfahren durchgehen und dann die Hacklösungen machen?
Gerne, gerne. Also, wo waren wir denn jetzt? Wir waren bei Videocrypt 2.
Genau, wir waren bei Videocrypt 2. Videocrypt 2, dasselbe wie Videocrypt 1, bis auf ein paar Details. Und das nächste auf der Liste ist dann Eurocrypt. Eurocrypt ist standardisiert im Rahmen von D2MAC. Das heißt, das Verfahren, wo die Komponenten des Signals getrennt übertragen werden. Und verwendet auch eine Rotation von Zeilen, genauso wie bei Videocrypt. Und der Algorithmus, das weiß man, um den Session Key zu gewinnen, mit dem man also die zwei Sekunden in dem Decoder Fernsehen gucken kann, der ist der DES-Algorithmus mit den Kantenproblemen, 56-Bit Keylänge und so weiter und so fort. Wird auch von relativ vielen Kanälen verwendet. Gibt es jetzt noch was zu sagen?
Das ist der andere Standard, der derzeit in Verwendung ist.
Der zweite von den drei wichtig. Der dritte Richtige ist Sister Nagra Vision, der technisch schon ein bisschen aufwendiger ist. Da werden nämlich die Zeilen miteinander vertauscht. Also nicht innerhalb der Zeile, sondern Zeilen miteinander.
Nein, das ist nicht ganz richtig. Sie werden nicht vertauscht, sie werden in einer neuen Reihenfolge gebracht.
Das ist dasselbe, würde ich sagen.
Naja, nee, wenn nur Zeile 2 und Zeile 5 vertauscht ist, Zeile 5 dann an Zeile 2 und Zeile 2 und Zeile 5 so ist.
Ich kann dir nachweisen, dass es identisch ist, aber das dauert nahe. Und zwar ist es so, dass in den Dekodern ein Buffer von 32 Zeilen ist und es können höchstens 32 Zeilen gleichzeitig gehalten werden. Dieses Verfahren Sister-Nagra-Visition wird zum Beispiel von Premiere verwendet. Wenn man sich das typische Premiere-Bild mal anguckt, dann sieht man, dass das eigentlich so relativ homogen aussieht, das ist ein bisschen verraschend, die Zeilen sind also ungefähr in der Gegend, wo sie hingehören, abgesehen von ein paar Ausreißern und vor allen Dingen sind am unteren Rand des Bildes schon die Zeilen des nächsten Halbbildes zu sehen.
Genau, 32 Stück an der Zahl. Und das braucht man, dieser Decoder braucht diese 32 Zeilen am untersten Bildrand, um die schon mal in seinen Speicher zu lesen, damit er, wenn er das erste unverschlüsselte Bild darstellen will, muss er ja schon die 32 Zeilen in die richtige Reihenfolge gebracht haben, um alle mindestens die erste Zeile auf den Bildschirm zu bringen. Deswegen ist also dieser Rand unten beim Premiere Bild. Das hat man vielleicht mal gesehen, wenn man schon über die Kanäle zappt, sieht man, dass das hier irgendwie komisch aussieht. Dass dann unten eine Kante ist. Wir haben das gerade hier mal Johnny vorgeführt.
Stani zeigt gerade mal drauf.
Oder ihr schaltet gerade mal Premiere ein, dann kann man das eigentlich wunderbar erklären.
Warum wurden da der Ton eigentlich nicht verschlüsselt?
Der Ton wirbt bei, und da haben wir den Unterschied zwischen Syster und Nagravision. Syster ist das deutsche Verfahren. Die denken sich, wenn man das Bild nicht sieht, dann hilft der Ton einem auch nicht. Das Gestöhne oder das Jagebrille beim Fußball, das hilft einem nicht besonders viel. Die Franzosen sehen das anders. Die benutzen eben Nagravision, da wird der Ton tatsächlich auch noch zusätzlich verschlüsselt.
Das ist eigentlich dasselbe. Die Tonverschlüsselung ist aber relativ simpel. Was da passiert ist, ist eine Frequenzinvertierung, und das kann man mit einer 5, 80-Schaltung wieder rückgängig machen. Das ist also nicht besonders sicher im Vergleich zu einer Verschlüsselung.
Wobei es eigentlich recht klug ist, den Sound nicht zu verschlüsseln, weil damit fixt man natürlich die Leute, die man im Reisen sehr viel besser an- und aussehen, hilft es besser beim Eintunen auf dem Fernseher, dass man auch wirklich weiß, auf welchem Sendermann man gerade ist. Es ist ja nicht so, dass man da irgendwie nichts erkennen würde. Es ist halt alles irgendwie sehr durcheinander gewürfelt.
Ich glaube aber darauf, dass das Absicht ist bei Premiere, dass man schon noch was erkennen muss.
Es ist teilweise natürlich Absicht, und teilweise durch die technischen Gegebenheiten, dass möglichst 32 Zeilen gleichzeitig gespeichert werden können. Und dass man die also nicht alle über das gesamte Bild verteilen kann, sondern das ist genau, das ist also ein...
Das heißt, jede Zeile ist quasi maximal 32 Zeilen von ihrer eigentlichen Position entfernt?
Nein, Tim, das ist nicht richtig. Und zwar können nur maximal 32 Zeilen in diesem Speicher gehalten werden. Es heißt aber nicht, dass nicht eine Zeile wirklich ganz bis zum Schluss des Viels im Speicher gehalten werden kann. Und die anderen 31 werden permanent ausgetauscht, spielt keine Rolle, und die 32 wird als letzte. Wir haben das mal getestet, also der maximale Abstand, den wir bis jetzt gemessen haben, war 192. Eine Zeile war 192 Zeilen von ihrem Ursprungswort entfernt.
Und wodurch kommt der Effekt, dass die Farbe geht ja hier irgendwie verloren? Das sieht einfach extrem schwarz-weiß aus und die Farbe zieht sich eher komplett über komplette Linien.
Genau, die Farbe sieht scheiße aus und das ist bei PAL so, das hatten wir vorhin schon, Phase Alternate Line. Bei PAL wird jetzt letzten Endes die Farbe aus zwei aufeinander folgenden Zeilen generiert. So ganz im Groben. Wenn die Zeilen jetzt nicht mehr, die, die aufeinander folgen, nicht mehr sind, die sind, die wirklich aufeinander folgen, dann muss diese PAL-Decodierung im Fernsehgerät natürlich in die Grütze gehen. Die Information steckt da schon noch drin. Der Fernseher decodiert sie nur falsch und stellt sie deswegen auch falsch dar. Ist nicht so, dass sie weg wird, es ist nur nicht mehr auf dem Bildschirm. Weil der Decoder halt Mist macht in dem Moment. Man müsste also erst die Zeilen in die richtige Reihenfolge bringen und dann würde der Fernseher auch die Farbe richtig decodieren. Und genau das macht ja der Decoder.
Genau, und wie man auch ohne Premierekarte die Zeilen in die richtige Reihenfolge bringt, das erklären wir dann gleich nach einer kleinen Pause.
Und das weiß ich wahrscheinlich viele schon fragen in der Zwischenzeit, nämlich wann werden die Leitungen geöffnet, um darüber zu reden, worüber ihr vielleicht einiges gelesen habt. Die Frage nämlich Premiere, Hack oder nicht oder inwiefern und wie geht das, was macht man da und so weiter und so fort. Das werden wir gleich tun, die Telefonleitungen öffnen nämlich nach dem Fritz Kurzinfo vor, vielleicht noch so ein, zwei einleitende Sätze zu dem, was dann kommt.
Ja, wir können ja ganz kurz mal erläutern, wie die prinzipielle Attacke gegen dieses eben beschriebene Systernager-Visionsverfahren funktioniert. Das basiert so ein bisschen auf der Theorie, dass in einem Videobild, wir hatten das vorhin schon mal angeschnitten, zwei aufeinander folgende Zeilen natürlich sehr ähnlich sind. Je kleiner die Zeilen sind, umso ähnlicher natürlich. Wir haben also 288 Zeilen. Das heißt, wenn wir nicht großen Kontrast, also waagerechte Linien in diesem Bild haben, dann sind diese Zeilen sehr ähnlich. Was man jetzt macht, man guckt sich erst mal prinzipiell, dieses einfachste Verfahren, man guckt sich alle Zeilen an. Und zwar jeweils in Bezug zu jeder anderen. Also man vergleicht jede Zeile mit jeder anderen. Das ist die brutale Gewaltmethode.
Das macht man aber nicht selber, sondern das lässt man ein bisschen an den Computer tun, weil sonst wird es echt...
Also man macht folgendes, man guckt ganz schnell...
Genau, der Computer nimmt also dieses Bild daher, guckt jetzt vergleicht jede Zeile mit jeder anderen, stellt jetzt fest über Fourier-Transformation oder über Zoomen oder da gibt es verschiedene Verfahren, wie ähnlich diese Zeilen sie sich sind, hat dann hinterher, hat man also ermittelt, welche Zeilen sich am ähnlichsten sind, das stellt man einfach in genau dieser Reihenfolge dar. Es gibt nämlich genau zwei Zeilen, die bleiben übrig. Eine hat kein Nachbar davor und eine hat kein Nachbar dahinter. Das eine ist die erste, das andere die letzte. In der Reihenfolge stellt man die Zeilen da und hat das fertig dekodierte Bild. Der Haken, das dauert viel zu lange.
Funktioniert also nicht.
Nee, funktioniert schon, aber braucht man für ein Bild, so naja, 10, 15, 20 Sekunden.
Wie man es dann richtig macht, da klären wir gleich nach dem Info, ja? Schaffst du nicht. Schaff ich? Nee, nicht in zwei Minuten. Mach ich ein bisschen entspannende Klaviermusik.
Ja, besser, viel besser, viel besser.
23.30 Uhr.
Grenzkontrollen vor dem morgigen Fußball-WM-Spiel Deutschland-Iran überprüft der Bundesgrenzschutz an allen Übergängen nach Frankreich, Autos und Züge auf gewaltbereite Hooligans. Es gab bereits mehrere Festnahmen und Waffenfunde. Fandungserfolg. Der mutmaßliche Doppelmörder von Sennewitz Büch ist offenbar gefasst. Im hessischen Hanau wurde ein Verdächtiger festgenommen. Abstimmung. Der Bundestag hat die Forderung von Bündnis 90 die Grünen nach einem Stoppnis-Transrapid-Projekt zurückgewiesen. Die Mehrheit der Abgeordneten sprach sich für den Bau der Magnetschwebebahn aus. Druck. Palästinenser Präsident Arafat hat den Rücktritt der meisten Minister seines Kabinetts angenommen. Das Parlament wirft ihnen Korruption vor. Unfall. Bei einem Schulbusunglück in der Nähe des sächsischen Ortes Bischdorf sind zwölf Kinder verletzt worden. Der Busfahrer hatte ein haltendes Auto übersehen und war beim Bremsen in einen Straßengraben gerutscht. Fußball bei der WM hat Paraguay am Abend Nigeria 3 zu 1 besiegt. Damit kam Paraguay nach Nigeria ins Achtelfinale. Spanien gewann gegen Bulgarien 6 zu 1. Frankreich-Dänemark trennten sich 2 zu 1, Saudi-Arabien-Südafrika 2 zu 2. Frankreich und Dänemark qualifizierten sich für die nächste Runde.
Wetter.
Morgen nach Frühnebel meist heiter und trocken 23 bis 26 Grad.
Verkehr.
A9 Nürnberg Richtung Berlin. Sperrung der Anschlussstelle Niemäck wegen Bauarbeiten. Eine Umleitung ist ausgeschildert. B109 von Berlin in Richtung Prenzlau. Zwischen Wandlitz und Prenzlau Verkehrsbehinderung durch einen Schwerlasttransport. Vorsicht bei der Annäherung.
Bike-Zirke mit dem Fritz. Kurz Info.
Fritz, ne? Wir präsentieren da was. Mulliganten, Fahrradkünstler und Rollbrettfahrer.
Die Vanswap Tour 98. Mit Bad Religion, 5 Sterne Deluxe, The Specials, Pitchshifter, Lag Wagon und und und und und und Skate und BMX Profis aus Amerika und als Überraschungsgäste die Reimpiraten aus Düsseldorf. Die Van Swap Tour 98 Mittwoch 9. September ab 16 Uhr in der Wuhlheide.
Chaosradio bei Fritz, jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Heute sehr technisch, das gibt es auch ab und zu zum Thema Fernsehen. Und ich hab vorhin erzählt, dass der CCC-Server www.ccc.de in den letzten Tagen enorm hohe Zugriffe hatte, also viele Besucher und das liegt an der Presse, die der CCC ja doch das Öfteren hat. Und in diesen Tagen eben wegen des Themas Premiere, da gingen durch verschiedene Medien groß die Schlagzeile Premiere gehackt.
Und das obwohl wir diesmal gar nicht schuld sind. Diese Software ist nämlich einfach aufgetaucht. Die hat ein anonymen bleiben wollender Franzose geschrieben, eine Software namens PCTV. Und es gibt auch eine zweite Software namens NagraTV. Und naja, interessanterweise konnte man damit halt Premiere gucken. Und zwar nicht nur mit einem Bild alle 20 Sekunden, sondern eher so 20 Bilder pro Sekunde.
Was heißt man konnte, man kann immer noch.
Man kann immer noch, genau. Und das sind außerdem drei Programme, eins für DOS, PCTV von Taz, nee von Gaston, ich weiß es gar nicht. Die heißen alle irgendwie, das sind Pseudonyme. Dann gibt es Nagra Deck für Windows. Das ist so eine reine Windows-Emplementation dieses Codes von PCTV. Und dann gibt das noch NagraTV für Linux. Und die Version ist auch die einzige, die wirklich interessant ist. Die geht nämlich in den Source Code.
NagraTV.
Ahja, das PCTV ist nur Binary.
Das ist nur Binary und das finden wir scheiße.
Genau.
Sowas wollen wir gar nicht. Es geht nämlich hierbei echt darum, dass Premiere hacken eine tolle Sache ist, aber Premiere gucken eher irgendwie langweilig und Fernseh gucken sowieso scheiße.
Jetzt muss man natürlich mal, wenn ihr übrigens Fragen dazu habt, die Hotline ist dann inzwischen auch geschaltet. Das heißt, ihr könnt hier anrufen.
Die Fris-Hotline ist geschaltet.
0331 für Potsdam. 70, 97, 110.
In der Praxis brauche ich also eine PC-Karte, die mich Fernsehempfang lässt.
Genau.
Da ich mich ja mit PCs nicht so besonders eng beschäftige, ist das Vollbild dann.
Das ist dann Vollbild.
Das ist Vollbild. Das heißt, ich kann endlich auf meinem sündhaft teuren Monitor das machen, was ich auch mit einem 200 Mark Teil machen kann. Wunderbar. Und mit Hilfe dieser Software kann ich dann auch Premiere gucken.
Und zwar je nachdem, welche Version du benutzt, unterschiedlich gut. Wir hatten das ja hier vorhin schon. Es gibt ein dieses Problem mit der Farbe. Das ist mittlerweile auch gelöst. Die Farbe ist übrigens von einem Deutschen entwickelt, der auch gerne nicht so unbedingt ins Öffentlich Licht gezerrt werden möchte. Der hat sich also überlegt, es kann doch nicht sein, dass das nicht geht und hat es dann doch geschafft. Das hat er in die Linux-Version eingebaut. Das ist auch die einzige, wie ich schon gesagt habe, für die es den Source gibt. Die anderen Autoren haben das dann in ihre Software übernommen, allerdings meines Erachtens nicht so ganz so gut. Und deswegen ist die Linux-Version eigentlich die beste von allen.
So, erstmal gucken, ob es da Fragen gibt. Hi, wer ist denn da?
Ich habe folgende Frage, und zwar, was für ein Verschließungsverfahren benutzen Sie denn, dass das doch so relativ einfach zu knacken war, das Ganze?
Vielleicht müssen wir das mit dem Knacken auch gleich nochmal relativieren.
Naja, also das ist so, dass Sie da ein eigenes Verschließungsverfahren verwenden, das nicht dokumentiert ist. Und das Problem bei diesem Verschließungsverfahren ist, dass es nicht so viele mögliche interne Zustände hat. Das heißt, es gibt bloß 32.768 verschiedene Abfolgen von Zufallszahlen bei Premiere. Und was diese Software so schnell macht, ist, dass sie sich sozusagen die Zahlen anguckt, die Zahlen miteinander vergleicht, dadurch relativ schnell drauf kommt, welcher dieser 2, 15 Zustände der Richtige ist.
Genau. Also im Prinzip ist das süß der Nagra-Vision und mit dem Schlüssel wird da gar nichts gemacht. Da wird auch nichts entschlüsselt in Wirklichkeit, sondern man guckt sich wirklich nur die Zeilen an, vergleicht die, guckt sich halt eben nicht alle an, sondern nur ein paar, ermittelt, wie die vertauscht sind, verwürfelt sind und schließt dann darauf, welcher der 32.768 Schlüssel verwendet wurde und mit dem ermittelten Schlüssel entschlüsselt man dann das gesamte Bild.
Das heißt, man kann nicht irgendwie jetzt so einen General-Schlüssel herausfinden, der dem ganzen zugrunde liegt.
Naja, der Witz ist...
Da steckt so ein General-Schlüssel drin.
Im Prinzip ja. Also das Ganze basiert auf einer Beobachtung. Man hat sich einfach sehr, sehr, sehr viele dieser Bilder angeguckt. Und aufgrund der Kenntnis des Patentes, der Patentschrift und noch ein bisschen anderer Kenntnis des Systems konnte man dann also ein Programm schreiben, das einem im Prinzip eine Liste generiert, aus der all diese 32.000 verschiedenen Schlüssel hergestellt werden. So, und wenn man die kennt, diese Liste, und die ist eben... Da gibt es genau zwei Stück für alle systemverschlüsselten Sender. Das ist einmal für Premiere und all die anderen Teleklub, ist das glaube ich auch noch viele französische, türkische und spanische Sender. Und da gibt es noch einen anderen, der ist für Kanal Plus in Frankreich. Und mit diesen beiden Schlüsseln, also mit diesen beiden, sagen wir mal, Generalschlüsseln, kann man eigentlich alle systemverschlüsselten Programme entschlüsseln.
Das ist ja praktisch. Dann könnten sich doch jetzt die Fernsehsender einfach sagen, wenn sie jetzt den Schlüssel nicht ausrücken wollten, müssten sie nur aufhören zu senden.
Das wäre sozusagen ganz toll, hätten wir das Problem. Das Problem endlich erledigt und keiner würde mehr Geld bezahlen müssen, um Scheinsfilme zu gucken oder Fußball. Achso, da gibt es ein Problem. Dieses Verfahren funktioniert bei Fußball nicht besonders gut. Und das freut mich persönlich natürlich ganz besonders. Weil beim Fußball gibt es so viel grünes Gras auf der Wiese, dass einfach die Informationen nicht ausreichen, um die Reihenfolge der Zeilen festzustellen. Und dann bleibt das Bild halt leider verschlüsselt.
Also war das Absicht, dass in den umlaufenden Versionen, die nicht fußballfähig sind.
Die sind nicht fußballfähig. Und ich persönlich finde das gut nochmal, hier der Hinweis, dieser ganze graben Stamm.
Ja, das haben wir jetzt gehört, Steini. Du stehst ja natürlich auch alleine da.
Das ist Wort, das ist ja auch ganz klar.
Andrea, sag doch auch mal was.
Ich gucke doch kein Fernsehen.
Auch sehr klug.
Hat das seine Fragen halbwegs beantwortet? So, wer ist da?
Hallo?
Da ist keiner mehr.
Wer ist da? Die hatten wohl alle die gleiche Frage.
Immer alle Lust auf Telekom.
Hallo, wer ist da?
Ich bin's nur.
Tschüss. Hallo, wer ist da?
Hallo, hier ist der Andreas.
Andreas, hallo.
Ich hab mal eine Frage. Und zwar geht's um Premiere. Dieses Programm, auf welcher Website kann ich ihn abrufen? Dürfen Sie das verbreiten oder?
Also da sollte man vielleicht sagen, dass Premiere raubzudekodieren selbstverständlich verboten ist.
Moment, Moment, Moment, das ist noch nicht so ganz raus. Also die Rechtslage ist unklar und es tendiert wahrscheinlich eher dazu, dass man da zumindest eine Leistungserschleichung begeht, aber so richtig fest steht das nicht. Man sollte aber ein bisschen vorsichtig damit sein. Also auf unseren Webseiten liegt dieses Software zum Beispiel nicht.
Nein, das dürfen wir auch nicht, das wollen wir auch nicht. Und das Problem dabei ist tatsächlich, dass ganz egal wie die Rechtslage ist, eins ist sicher, es ist nicht erlaubt, ohne dafür zu bezahlen, Premiere oder andere verschlüsselte Sender zu gucken. Das ist nicht erlaubt.
Also in anderen verschlüsselten Sender würde ich mich da wieder mit dir streiten wollen.
Es gibt allerdings viele Leute, die in den letzten Tagen unsere Website angeklickt haben und in Folge dessen sicherlich auch an den Ort gekommen sind.
Da hab ich eben auch gerade erfahren, dass hier Chaos Computer Club auf Tritt sendet. Und dann dachte ich mir, schalt's mal rein, das ist ziemlich interessant hier.
Du hörst das zum ersten Mal. Bitte? Du hörst das zum ersten Mal, sozusagen.
Auf der Seite bin ich eigentlich öfters, aber dass uns so Fritz kommt, das Chaos Radio, das wusste ich nicht.
Ach, siehste, dann bist du ab jetzt immer jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat dabei, ist doch schön.
Wisst ihr was Neues über diese Fusion von Premiere und DF1?
Ja, das ist vom Tisch. Die Kommission hat dagegen entschieden. Das hat sie aber nicht ohne Grund. Bertelsmann wollte auch nicht mehr so recht, weil die da reichlich jetzt... Es gab einen Kompromissvorschlag der Kommission und der war für Bertelsmann nicht akzeptabel. Mehr oder weniger, die haben sie also dagegen gesperrt. Und das wird sehr wahrscheinlich das Ende von Kirchs Digitalfernsehen sein.
Ich bin noch nicht so sicher.
Also es ist angekündigt jetzt, aktuell, ich glaube jetzt diese Woche, Anfang der Woche haben sie angekündigt, das einzustellen.
Was machen denn die Leute, die da irgendwann mal einen Tausend dafür bezahlt haben?
Das wird jetzt natürlich noch weiter, aber die betrieben eine gewisse Zeit, solange bis sich da was erklärt hat. Sie suchen jetzt auch massiv nach anderen Partnern, haben aber noch nicht richtig was gefunden. Unter dem Tisch mauscheln sie auch schon wieder mit Bertelsmann für eine andere Geschichte, also das wird spannend bleiben.
Du hast gerade schade gesagt, hast du DF1?
Ich habe DF1, ja. Also ich bin DF1 Kunde. Und ich habe mich mit meinem Nachbar zusammengetan und der hat Premiere digital. Also wenn ich mal Premiere schauen möchte, dann hole ich mir zwar einfach seine Karte. Und das funktioniert auch wunderbar. Aber es ist eben schade, dass DF1 jetzt Schluss machen möchte.
Naja, das würde es noch eine ganze Zeit lang geben. Das können Sie sich gar nicht erlauben, jetzt da alle rauszuschmeißen. Und es wird sicher eine Lösung geben. Aber Sie haben natürlich, um jetzt erst mal alle zu erschrecken, gesagt, so wir stellen das ein, die Arbeitsplätze gehen flöten, ihr seid schuld, einfach so eine Trotzreaktion.
Ja, habe ich noch mal eine Frage, und zwar, wenn ich von meinem Nachbar diese Premiere-Karte nehme und schieb die bei mir rein in die D-Box. So. Und wechsel dann wieder und gebe sie ihm wieder diese Karte. Dann hat er für einen Tag lang DF1. Und das passiert jedes Mal. Die kann man rein.
Aha, das wissen wir auch nicht. Das ist aber spannend, da werden wir mal nachgucken.
Das hat mich echt gewundert. Wir haben das ein paar Mal ausprobiert, das ging jedes Mal. 24 Stunden so rum, ne?
Ist das auch mit der DF1-Karte und Premiere umgekehrt?
Ne, das eben nicht, das hat mich ja geärgert.
Das heißt, er tut seine Premiere-Karte bei dir rein, tut sie danach wieder bei sich rein und dann kann er DF1 gucken.
Dann kann er DF1 zu 24.
Genau einen Tag.
Schauen wir mal. Das ist ein schöner Hinweis, Dankeschön.
Das hat jedes Mal.
Da werden wir mal nachforschen. Klingt wie ein Bug.
Sag mal, was zahlst du dafür für DF1?
Ich bezahle 59 Mark im Monat.
60 Mark mit Decoder?
Also für einen Decoder 19 Mark 90 für diese D-Box.
Und die 60 Mark sind zusammen mit Decoder?
Ja, mit Decoder und Super.
Um da jetzt auch mal ein bisschen untechnisch ranzugehen, stellt sich die Frage, ich hab eine Zeit lang Premiere gehabt. Also an sich nicht sportinteressierter Mensch. Es ist zwar schon ganz hübsch, dass Filme ohne Werbung laufen, aber für mich hat sich das nicht rentiert. Ich finde es einfach zu teuer. Also ich finde 50 Mark im Monat oder sogar 60 für DF1. Wenn ich keine Werbung habe, wunderbar, da zahl ich auch was für. Das kann ich akzeptieren, aber ich finde das wirklich zu teuer. Rentiert sich das für dich wirklich? Findest du 60 Mark okay?
Also ich finde das eigentlich voll okay. Doch allein weil das Filmangebot ist wesentlich besser als bei diesen öffentlich-rechtlichen oder irgendwie ATL Sat1 Pro7. Diese Filme...
Keine Werbung, ne?
Ja, das ist natürlich eine von den Sachen, die mich jetzt überwogen hat, DS1 zu abonnieren.
Aber du zahlst fast 7000 Mark dafür im Jahr.
Wie viel?
Quatsch, das ist 700.
Ich vergesse es nicht.
Ja okay, das ist mir aber irgendwo wert.
Also du guckst sozusagen gerne Fernsehen?
Du guckst gerne viel.
Bitte?
Also meine Frau schaut sehr viel Fernsehen und mein Kind.
Wie alt ist das Kind, anderthalb?
Diese Kinderkanäle von DF1, die angeboten werden, die sind eigentlich sehr gut, würde ich sagen.
Aber du hast nicht den Eindruck, dass Fernsehen im Allgemeinen irgendwie so ein bisschen unkommunikativ ist oder sowas? Also vor der Glotze verblöden oder so?
Nee, okay, ich beschäftige mich auch viel mit dem PC.
Auch mit deinem Kind?
Mit meinem Kind auch, ja.
Das finde ich ja irgendwie essenziell bei sowas.
Ja, okay, aber irgendwann brauchen das die Kinder mal.
Das ist richtig.
Diese Computergeschichte, ne. Geht hier immer weiter voran oder sowas.
Na gut.
Ja, hatst du noch eine Frage?
Nee, okay, das war's eigentlich schon. Dann bedanke ich dich bei euch, ne. Und macht weiter so, ne.
Das war eine interessante Information.
Ich denke, dass es viele Leute gibt, die gerne Fernsehen gucken.
Ja, natürlich, ansonsten.
Das ist ja auch nichts ungewöhnliches. Ich bin nicht selber immer wieder dabei, wie ich gerne Fernsehen gucke. Allerdings zählt das nicht alle an.
Das ist für jedes Suchtmittel immer mocht. Dann halt immer mehr und immer öfter.
Ja, das Niveau sinkt dann immer am besten. Aber Tim, weißt du, seit es diesen Premiere-Hack gibt, den gibt es jetzt glaube ich seit Ende Mai, habe ich genau zweimal Premiere geguckt. Damit einfach nur zu gucken, ob es geht. Aber es ist nicht so, dass mich das wirklich...
Ich muss ja auch sagen, dass ich da dann auch die öffentliche Stellungnahme von Premiere extrem okay finde, weil die halt sagen, ist nicht so schlimm. Also die haben gesagt, dass sie das nicht weiter stört und dagegen auch weiter nicht vorgehen werden. Das ist das letzte Statement, was ich gehört habe.
Das aber wahrscheinlich auch nur deshalb, weil sie erstens sowieso schon auf dem Pfad zur rein digitalen Übertragung sind über D-Box. Also diese analoge Verschlüsselungstechnik, die sie derzeit anwenden, ist ja ein Auslaufmodell. Die setzen sich einfach an ihr Excel-Spreadsheet, rechnen aus, was kostet es uns jetzt zwei Jahre lang noch dagegen anzugehen oder ist das für uns nicht sogar noch mehr Kundenwerbung, weil wenn das alte dann sowieso nicht mehr ist, dann haben noch mehr Leute sich irgendwie davon abhängig gemacht. Also jetzt mal komplett umgedreht die Argumentation. Ich kann die verstehen. Angenommen, es wäre jetzt eine Technologie, auf die sie noch weitere 5, 6 Jahre setzen würden, könnte ich mir gut vorstellen, dass sie da ein bisschen anders...
Ja, aber es zeigt doch einiges im Gegensatz zu anderen Firmen, wo jetzt unabhängig ob der CCC irgendwelche Geschichten gemacht hat oder andere Leute, da gibt es ja oft eine Überreaktion von Firmen, dass die sagen, um Gottes Willen und bla, und das ist natürlich die riesen Anti-Werbung dann auch, und da finde ich das schon ganz clever, dass Premiere sagt, ok, da gibt es ein paar Leute, die haben Computer und von denen gibt es ein paar, die haben eine PC-Karte und von denen wiederum gibt es ein paar, die besorgen nicht dieses Programm und haben nichts anderes zu tun als Premiere auf ihrem Computer zu gucken. Und das ist ok.
Man muss ja auch den Rechner nun da irgendwie anstöpseln, womöglich neben dem Fernseher stellen oder irgendwie sowas. Das ist schon ein bisschen aufschweigen.
Also das ist ja eigentlich eher ein Sport und ein Hobby und mal gucken, ob es geht und so weiter. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute sich wirklich davorsetzen und zehn Stunden täglich Premiere gucken, wahrscheinlich die wenigsten.
Du hast auch ein Problem, du kannst es nicht aufnehmen, jedenfalls noch nicht so gut. Erstens sind die Qualität nicht so prickelnd, zweitens Fußball und diese Filme mit diesem viel rosa Haut und so, die dekodiert er nicht so gut, weil er einfach die Farben zu...
Zu viel denselben Farbton hat, ist ein Problem.
Ist ein Problem und du kannst es halt nicht gut aufzeichnen. Da wird zwar gerade dran gearbeitet, dass das Bild auch hinten aus einer geeigneten Videokarte wieder rauskommt, aber das ist nicht Plug and Play, da steckst du nicht rein und geht, sondern musst du richtig frickeln, dann musst du womöglich einen Linux installieren und richtig aufwandtreiben, das ist schon noch...
Zehn verschiedene Parameter konfigurieren.
Jaja, das ist echt nicht so ganz so easy, es ist nicht. Und deswegen, solange wird es auch da keinen Bedarf für die geben, irgendwas zu tun.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein sehr interessanter Hack, weil es nicht irgendwie so ist, Schlüssel gesucht, Schlüssel gefunden und jetzt ist alles, alle Türen stehen offen, sondern der Premiere Hack, der ist einfach super elegant. Der guckt halt irgendwie, ja, da gibt es ein bestimmtes Problem, das lässt sich jetzt irgendwie nicht lösen, dass da irgendwie ein geheimer Schlüssel ist. Und dann geht er halt irgendwie so dran vorbei und macht das eben eher auf so eine Wahrnehmungsart und Weise. Wie könnte denn das alles so zusammenfassen, untersucht das Bild und schaut sich das im Prinzip an. Also ich rede jetzt von diesem Programm. Und daraufhin stellt er eben auf einmal bestimmte Schlüssel fest und der Programmierer hat halt mit Erfolg das Ganze ins Source Code gegossen. Das ist natürlich hochgradig kreativ.
Vielleicht noch ein paar Worte zum Ursprung dieses ganzen Dings. Die eigentliche Idee, nämlich Zeilen zu vergleichen, hat eigentlich Markus Kuhn damals, seines Zeichens, ein begnadeter Mathematiker und Denker, mal formuliert für Videokrypt und das auch in einem Source Code namens AntiSky veröffentlicht. Und zwar hat er dann die Zeilen, die in der Mitte zerhackt und vertauscht sind, einfach miteinander verglichen und solange verschoben, bis sie also möglichst gleichmäßig wieder da her kamen. Dann war irgendwo in der Mitte eine linie, die senkrechte Linie. Da waren nämlich alle Bruchpunkte untereinander. Und die hat er an Rand geschoben. Und dann stimmte das Videokrypt-Bild wieder.
Ich würde sagen, dass er auf einer Cray T3e mit mehreren Dutzend Prozessoren sogar in der Lage war, in schwarz-weiß ein Echtzeitbild zu sehen.
Heutzutage geht das in schlechter Qualität auf dem Pensum 133 mit einem Bild pro Sekunde. Also nichts, womit man Fernsehen gucken könnte. Dieses Verfahren aber war ursprünglich der Auslöser für das Programm Anti-Nagra. Das macht diese brutale Methode, vergleicht alle Zeilen miteinander.
Wobei es dann noch eine zweite Quelle gibt, und zwar für die Seekam-Variante von Syster. Gab es ja schon eine Hardware-Lösung, die sich jedoch die Phasenlage des Farbsignals angeguckt hat am Anfang der Zeile und dadurch feststellen konnte, ob eine Zeile eine gerade Zeile war oder eine ungerade Zeile. Und dadurch darauf gekommen ist, wie der Key war. Und das funktionierte nur für Seekam, nur für Kanal Plus, und es war eine Hardware-Lösung, die man kaufen konnte. Und die clevere Idee war jetzt, diese beiden Sachen miteinander zu verbinden. Also auf der einen Seite das Vergleichen der Zeilen miteinander zu nehmen, auf der anderen Seite den Teil, der, wenn man wusste, wie die Zeilen ungefähr zusammengehören, den Key errechnet und daraus eine Software zu machen.
Ich bin vom CCC, zum Radio, über den Link, also über die Informationen, aber die ganzen anderen Links oben, die sind alle tot.
Na ja, tot sind sie nicht, sie sind gerade outdated, weil es sich auf der Eurosatzseite geändert hat. Dann nimmst du einfach mal ein paar Buchstaben von der UAL hinten weg und dann kommst du schon etwa dahin, wo du hin willst.
Ach so, funktioniert das.
Das Problem ist, dass sich das da alles sehr sehr schnell ändert und wenn da mal einer, zwei, drei Tage nicht da ist, dann stimmt das alles nicht mehr. Wir werden das also umgehend auch wieder korrigieren.
Da liegt einer schneller auf als wir, ist erstaunlich.
Ich wollte von euch mal wissen, macht ihr das nur in eurer Freizeit? Oder was habt ihr für eine Ausbildung gemacht?
Wo habt ihr euer Gesamtwissen her?
Ist das alles nur Freizeitbereich oder?
Ja, naja, sicher nicht.
Wir beschäftigen uns mit Blumenzucht.
Ich bin Surflehrer, nicht im Internet.
Also wir haben auch schon alle mit Computern zu tun, aber so die Sachen, die wir im Rahmen des CCC machen, haben wir mit unserer beruflichen Tätigkeit eigentlich nicht zum Hut.
Aber das ist schon so, dass das Wissen, das man sowohl auf der einen als auch auf der anderen Seite aufbaut, natürlich symbiotisch das sich gegenseitig ergänzt.
Ich denke, es gibt drei Quellen im Wesentlichen. Bücher, das Internet und andere Leute. Manche Leute sind der Meinung, man müsste auch noch zur Universität gehen, um das zu komplizieren.
Damit kompliziert man das.
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht wird man ja noch ein bisschen intelligenter. Keine Ahnung. Ich war zum Beispiel nicht da. Man muss nicht unbedingt Informatik studieren.
Ich war auch noch ganz kurz an der Uni, bis ich dachte, das ist mir jetzt echt zu gut.
Das ist halt eher aus dem Interesse heraus. So wie man staunend neben 14-Jährigen Städte mit dem Skateboard Dinge machen, wo man das Gefühl hat, dass physikalische Grenzbereiche locker durchschritten werden. Das erscheint manchmal auch bei Computergeschichten, aber letzten Endes ist das alles nur Brot und Salz. Wenn man erst mal verstanden hat, wie die Dinge grundsätzlich funktionieren, dann ist auch relativ viel schnell entzaubert und man kann sich vielen Themen schnell ernähren.
Und ihr macht das im Rahmen von einem Club? Ich hab's vorhin nicht mitbekommen.
Ja genau, wir sind der Chaos Computer Club. Das ist ein Computerverein, der schon relativ lange besteht und sich nicht nur auf eine Stadt beschränkt. Schwerpunktmäßig ging das mal in Hamburg los. Mittlerweile passiert auch in Berlin sehr viel. Und in ein paar anderen Städten, Köln zum Beispiel. Wir sind halt interessiert an der anderen Seite. Bei uns ist vielleicht sehr viel mehr das Interesse daran ausgeprägt, wie die Dinge trotzdem funktionieren, obwohl jemand meint, das würde eigentlich nicht gehen.
Herauszufinden, was die Welt im Innersten zusammenhält.
Und von der Finanzierung her?
Oder woher dieses Geräusch kommt.
Genau, das würden wir jetzt auch zum Beispiel ganz gerne wissen. Von einem Schnurrlostelefon, was kein Akku mehr hat.
Genau.
Finanzierung, naja Gott, wir haben halt irgendwie ein paar Ausgaben, haben ein paar Einnahmen im Wesentlichen, das Mitgliederbeiträge, wie das jeder andere Verein auch macht.
Ja, wir brauchen auch nicht viel. Ich meine, wir haben so ein paar...
Sie sind auf jeden Fall nicht reich oder so was.
Es gibt bei uns auch keine Angestellten, wie manche Leute manchmal vermuten.
Ja, wir machen das also alles freiwillig.
Und was ist mit mir?
Du kriegst ja Geld, aber nicht von uns.
Ja, jedem Angestellte kriegt noch Geld.
Ja, aber nicht von uns.
Ihr habt ja halt jemand anderes gefunden, der einen Angestellten bezahlt.
Ja, okay, das ist unser Trick.
So, deine ersten Frage beantwortet.
Hallo, ich bin's, Nina, guten Tag. Ich hab eine Frage, also das heißt eine mehrere.
Schieß los, hör mal los.
Ja, also erstens, wenn ich Fritz über Kabel empfangen möchte, was muss ich dann machen? Also, ich kann...
www.fritz.de anklicken, da gibt's eine Seite, wo das drauf steht.
Nein, ich hab hier nichts, weil die kann ich nicht anklicken. Ich möchte in meinem Radio Fritz über Kabel empfangen. Entschuldigung, ich hab jetzt eben nicht zugehört die Zeit.
Warte mal, Lina, ganz kurz.
Wenn Fritz im Berliner Kabel, dann 89, 85.
So, erste Frage beantwortet.
Meine erste Frage?
Doch.
Pass auf, ich mach's nochmal.
Wenn Fritz im Berliner Kabel, dann 89, 85.
89, 85.
Das ist die Frequenz, die du einstellen musst.
Naja, aber ich hab doch diese Kabel nicht.
Dann brauchst du es doch nicht über Kabel empfangen.
So gehe ich mich so undeutlich aus.
Wenn du Fritz über Kabel empfangen willst, dann brauchst du erstmal einen Kabelanschluss. Von der Telekom.
Von der Telekom auch noch?
Kannst du auch direkt an TSS, wenn...
Die zweite Frage.
Direkt muss ich mich dann holen?
TSS Elektronik. Wie heißen die TSS und so weiter?
Ruf deine Haus...
Telefonbuch D, Deutsche Telekom, da gibt's eine extra Nummer für Kabelanschlüsse.
Oder probier einfach alle Telefonnummern durch, bis du erfolgreich hast.
Kabelanschluss, Nummer.
Ist dir eigentlich aufgefallen, dass wir heute nicht das Thema Kabelanschluss und die krieg ich fritzumlaufen haben?
Ja, ich hab ja auch noch andere...
Ja, wir sind auch nicht die Support-Hotline der Telekom und auch nicht die Support-Hotline von Radiofrips.
So, also dann wollte ich noch fragen, ich fand es ja sehr interessant über die Premiere-Sache, die ihr erzählt habt. Das war mir ja völlig neu. Schön. Ja, so was gibt es auch noch, stellt euch das mal vor.
War das jetzt...
Bitte. Und, ja... Das war eigentlich keine Frage, sagen wir nicht.
Nina, eigentlich wolltest du mal wieder anrufen. Du wolltest mal wieder im Radio sein, Nina.
Riecht doch grad, oder?
Ja, du hast es geschafft.
Nina, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Alles klar, tschüss.
Nina ist an allen möglichen Radiosendern. Man muss mal andere Radiosender ab und zu einschalten, dann hört man Nina auch. Hallo?
Ja, noch mal, Uwe. Könnt ihr euch noch mal ein kleines bisschen über die Hardware-Voraussetzungen auslassen, weil ich sehe schon ganz viele User mit einem Antennenkabel an ihrem Laptop rumformieren.
Das kann man vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen näher erklären.
Also prinzipiell funktioniert dieses Verfahren auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise mit jedem Computer, der eine Videokarte hat. Nein, das ist nicht richtig. Grundsätzlich gibt es da keine Einschränkung. Man muss nur das Videobild irgendwie da rein kriegen. Wenn man möchte, dass es toll ist, dann also der Sourcecode ist verfügbar. Den kann man anpassen. Da geht es auf jedem Computer. Das haben Leute für SGI Computer schon gemacht. Das geht sicher auch mit Apple. Da kenne ich keine aktuelle Implementation. Das löchert uns also nicht. Deswegen, wenn du das haben willst, dass das toll ist und du willst es in schwarz-weiß, dann brauchst du mindestens ein Pentium 133 MHz und eine Videokarte, eine Videotv-Karte, wo ein besonderer Prozessor drauf ist, nämlich der BT848. Das ist auf verschiedenen Videokarnit, will ich jetzt keine Schleichwärmung für. Die sind eigentlich alle gut. Da kannst du eigentlich fast nehmen, was du willst. Und wenn du das in Farbe besonders toll haben willst, dann brauchst du ein Pentium 266 am besten, mit toll schneller Grafikkarte und einem Linux drauf und auch eben eine solche Karte. Pentium 2 und Pentium Pro funktioniert merkwürdigerweise nicht so gut wie der Pentium 266. Warum das so ist, weiß keiner.
Muss ich einen Pentium dafür haben?
Ja, mindestens.
Ich hab was anderes.
Du kannst auch so einen AMD K6 nehmen. Man muss nicht Intel haben.
Na ja, nur gut. Pentium ist bei mir alles, dieses System.
Ja, eine Geschwindigkeitsausrichtung. Pentium 133 sei mal so der Markstein. Damit kann man irgendwie schwarz-weiß-preniere gucken.
Und Farbe funktioniert ab 200.
Also ich hab zu dem Computerhändler meines Vertrauens gesagt, ich brauch leider auch einen PC. Und ich will ganz wenig Geld dafür ausgeben. Und er muss trotzdem was können. Und dann hat er mir was anderes als Pentium hingestellt.
Also, dann seh ich auch ein, dass Premiere da ziemlich gelassen drauf reagiert. Wenn also mehr oder weniger nur High-End-Geräte dafür geeignet sind, einfach hat er Mark.
Aber Aldi gibt's das jetzt für 2000 Mark? Ja, nicht mal. Aber trotzdem ist es so, dass einfach verdammt viele Leute sich solche Computer kaufen.
Guck mal, wenn du ein Jahr lang... Also ich will jetzt da keine Werbung für machen, wie gesagt. Ich gehe davon aus, dass das verboten ist. Aber wenn du ein Jahr lang die 50 Mark nicht bezahlst, da hast du den halben Computer schon drin und du kannst mit dem Computer echt noch andere Sachen machen, außer Premiere gucken.
Abgesehen davon hatte ich auch mal einen High-End-Computer. Es war ein 48633 mit 12 Megabyte RAM.
Stimmt. Ich hab schon beim 286er mit 12 Megahertz gestaut. Aber wir wollen jetzt nicht wieder unsere Kindergeschichten ausarten. Also es geht ja auch nicht darum, jetzt den PC dafür zu kaufen, sondern es ist halt so, dass viele Leute haben sowas. Und ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass Premiere nicht zuletzt deshalb ein bisschen entspannter ist. Vielleicht liegt es ja auch daran, dass es vielleicht mal eine deutsche Ausnahme ist in Deutschland, dass so ein Laden auch mal entspannt reagiert.
Ich finde das eigentlich unsympathisch, muss ich sagen.
Ich finde das auch okay, wenn Sie da nicht so einen Stress machen. Aber an alle nochmal da draußen, die unbedingt Premiere gucken wollen, ihr spart euch ganz viel Ärger und ganz viel Stress, wenn ihr das einfach abonniert, wenn ihr es unbedingt braucht. Das ist wirklich echt viel entspannter und am Ende nicht teurer. Es ist wirklich nur eine Spielerei, das mit einem Computer zu machen. Ganz ehrlich.
Wenn ihr noch weitere Fragen habt, ruft uns an. 0331 für Potsdam, 7097110. Ralf hat noch mehrere Fragen, sagt er, hi Ralf.
Hi, ja und zwar habe ich Fragen, bin ich jetzt schon online?
Bist online.
Einwandfrei. Ja, mein ganz Grundsatz, ja ich habe nur aus dem Computer und da habe ich nur Windows drauf, ja. Und TV-Card habe ich auch und die Software habe ich mir nur schon runtergeladen, ja. Und Fernsehen gucken kann ich auch und habe auch dieses verschlüsselte Premiere-Signal. Ja, jetzt habe ich mir die Software heruntergeladen, hier dieses Naga-Deck, Decoder, wie sich das nennt, war. Und wie muss ich jetzt vorgehen, um das zu gucken? Ich starte meine Dinge, dieses Naga-TV, oder wie fange ich da an?
Hast du denn die richtige TV-Karte?
Ja, das ist die von Hauptauge hier, die...
Da musst du nur machen, was in dem Rhythmus drin steht, und dann geht das. Also jetzt erklären wir, was du da im Island tun musst.
Ist das irgendwie kompliziert?
Doch, das ist kompliziert, ja. Das geht jetzt nicht aus, in zwei Minuten ist das nicht erläutert. Das ist auch Quatsch, das jetzt im Radio zu machen. Lies das durch, da steht da alles bei, was du machen musst, und dann geht das.
Von der Telekom die Kästen, die wir jetzt aufhängen. Die sind ja normalerweise verblombt, sind beinahe jetzt nicht verblombt.
Welche Kästen meinst du?
Na die Hausanschlüsse sozusagen.
Normalerweise sind die abgeschlossen, die sind gar nicht verblombt, die sind normalerweise abgeschlossen.
Ich gucke jetzt darüber, zahle aber nicht meine Gebühren im Monat.
Na du Frechdachs.
Wenn du jetzt noch deinen Namen und deine Adresse nennst, würde ich sagen, relativ groß.
Das wird immer größer.
Guck mal hier aus dem Play und sag deine Nummer an.
Ich bin ein kabelfernsehen Betreiber in Berlin.
Nee, ich denke, also ich weiß nicht, irgendwann kommen die Herren von der Firma TSS, stellen fest, aha, da ist Kabel dran, das soll da nicht dran sein, dann machen die das wieder ab. Wenn das beim nächsten Mal wieder dran ist, dann klopfen sie bei dir und fragen nicht, was das soll.
Uns ist nicht bekannt, dass man durch eine Fernmessung das Anschalten des Kabels rauskriegen kann. Wir wissen allerdings auch nicht alles. Das muss man dazu nochmal erwähnen.
Nee, aber es ist technisch sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass sie das aus der Ferne rauskriegen, aber die kommen da regelmäßig vorbei.
Muss es nicht. Genau.
Also schön aufpassen.
Schön aufpassen, immer schön zahlen, das ist ein guter Tipp. Hallo, wer ist denn da? Hi, Mathe.
Will ich bei Fritze?
Soll ich dir die jetzt stellen?
Nö, am besten du legst auf und rufst 110 an. Na ja, dobe Frage, dobe Antwort. Ja, frag einfach.
Und kann ich mir den Decoder kopieren und dann mit dem anderen Decoder gucken?
Was für ein Decoder?
Dann Premiere Decoder.
Uns ist kein Verfahren bekannt, mit dem man den Premiere Key kopieren kann.
Ach, den kann man nicht kopieren?
Nö. Es ist uns nicht bekannt, ich weiß nicht, ob man das kann.
Man kann das, aber das notwendige Equipment gibt es nicht oft in Europa.
Ach so, das macht man einfach mit so einem Chip.
Du, das lest du in die Mikrowelle, lest den anderen auch in die Mikrowelle. Da machst du Anstellers auf zwölf Minuten und dann hast du den Kopf.
Das Problem ist, dass da nicht einfach nur Daten drauf sind, sondern da ist ein Prozessor drin. Du redest mit dem Protokoll, das ist ein richtiger Computer, dieser Schlüssel. Den kannst du nicht einfach kopieren. Du kannst ja auch nicht deinen Computer kopieren, du musst da die Teile nachkaufen, nur kannst du das halt leider nicht, weil das halt am Stück ist.
Ja klar. Ach so, das ist ja nicht wie so ein normaler Chip, ne?
Nö, da ist nicht einfach nur Daten drin, sondern das ist wirklich ein Computer in diesem Zeit-Schlüssel.
Also diese Chipkarte hat halt nicht nur die Intelligenz, um Daten zu speichern, das ist also nicht RAM oder so oder ROM, sondern es handelt sich wirklich um einen vollwertigen Computer. So ein Prozessor und Programm und ein bisschen RAM und da läuft richtig was und der kommuniziert auch, nämlich über diese Goldkontakte, die oben auf der Karte drauf sind und das eine Gerät, der Premiere Decoder, redet halt mit der Karte und die stimmen sich sozusagen darüber ab, was am besten hier zu tun ist. Und ganz klar kann man das halt genauso wenig einfach kopieren, wie man einen kompletten Desktop-Computer kopieren kann, weil ich meine, wenn du das Problem gelöst hast, dann befinden wir uns im Star Trek-Zeitalter.
Der Materie-Computer, yeah!
Wir haben ja immer noch ein paar Jahre.
Es ist natürlich möglich, das kompliziert zu kopieren und zwar sind im Internet vor zwei Jahren die sogenannten X-Files aufgetaucht. Und zwar war das das ausgelesene ROM von einer Sky-10-Serienkarte. Und es gab dann eine Software auf dem PC, die den Prozessor auf der Chipkarte emuliert hat und das ROM-Image, das aus dieser Karte ausgelesen wurde, verwendet hat, um dann mithilfe eines Interfaces, sozusagen mit dem PC diese Karte komplett zu simulieren.
Und nur damals, und das geht mittlerweile auch nicht mehr wirklich.
Genau, also es ist mit einem erheblichen Aufwand verbunden, so was zu kopieren.
Das Protokoll.
Läuft dann darauf hinaus, dass man den Chip aufmachen muss und direkt an den Chip rangehen muss, das ROM vielleicht von Hand lesen muss und dann Mikroskop und mit Micro-Prob-Nidels und so weiter und so fort. Also definitiv nichts für den Heimgebrauch. Braucht man schon irgendwie Uni-Equipment oder Besseres?
Okay, also das war ja komplett beantwortet alles.
Wunderbar, so soll es sein.
Haben wir noch einen Ruf an?
Ja, noch einen probieren.
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Ich bin's nochmal, hallo.
Das ist noch eine Frage.
Ja, ist klar.
Mir ist halt nichts mit dem Thema zu tun.
Ich kann gleich dazu die ganze Zeit.
Sag mal, was machst du?
Ich find's wirklich erstaunlich irgendwie. Man hört dich Abend für Abend.
Ja?
Was machst du sonst noch so?
Also abends.
Wir dürfen doch auch mal fangen.
Ich hör immer Radio hören, jeden Abend.
Du hörst immer Radio und rufst dann da gleich an.
Nein, ich ruf natürlich nur an, wenn ich da was wissen will. Also ich mach dir doch die Sendung da, oder?
Wann hast du zum letzten Mal net mit Freunden zusammen gegessen abends, ohne Radio zu hören? Hast du eine Platte raufgelegt oder eine CD reingeschmissen?
Ja, also Musik muss ich schon immer um mich haben. Ansonsten muss ich ja den Straßenlärm ertragen und die Bauarbeiter.
Die Bauarbeiter? Ich kann den Lied singen.
Da kann man wieder zusammengläsigen.
Womit wir zur Frage kommen würden?
Ja, danke schön. Ich hab die ganze Zeit über das Equipment jetzt ja auch erzählt. Aber nicht wo man das bekommen kann. Also bei Herty oder bei Chaosrad oder so jetzt ohne Werbung zu machen. Aber ihr müsst euch schon mal auch wieder deutlich werden.
War das ein Computer?
Nein, im welchen denn?
Jeder Computerladen hat Computer, deswegen heißen die so.
Und dann kaufst du den Computer und dann bildest du die Software drauf und dann funktioniert das. Du brauchst halt noch diese TV-Karte dazu.
Genau und du musst wissen, wie das geht.
Willst du mich Freitag wieder anrufen?
Genau oder nächsten Donnerstag?
Oder Dienstag, das ist glaube ich sehr günstig.
Oder nächsten Mittwoch.
Aber nach 22 Uhr. Mann, da hat man schon mal weibliche Anrufe.
Also man kann das natürlich noch mal zusammenfassen, nur damit das klar ist, wenn ihr einen Computer kaufen wollt, dann solltet ihr in einen Computerladen gehen.
Danke für diesen Zirkus.
Danke schön.
Hi, wer ist denn da?
Ne, du bist jetzt in dieser Vorschleife.
Ja, das ist ja das Problem.
Das ist jetzt erst ein Test.
Das geht ja schon früher an.
Egal.
Meine Frage. Ne, das ist jetzt erst der Test, ob wir dich durchstellen auf Sendung. Du musst eine Frage beantworten.
Ja, dann frag mich mal.
Wer ist in Gruppe B weitergekommen bei der Fußball-WM? Eie, das ist leider falsch. Da müssen wir den nächsten Anruf voran nehmen. Hallo, wer ist denn da? Jo, wer bist denn du?
Ich bin Bernd.
Hallo, Bernd.
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich erst mal fragen, wie man noch mal in den Website reinkommt.
In unsern hier, www.fritz.de, slash, also querstrich und dann speakers.
Ja, da bin ich schon immer, aber irgendwie sind da nur 300 Shats voran, Kuschelecke und so was.
Nee, dann gehst du auf den falschen. Du hast links, müsstest du, wenn dein Browser Frames unterstützt, dann müsstest du links irgendwie so die Möglichkeit haben, aus verschiedenen Shats zu wählen.
Ja, eigentlich unterstützt er Frames, aber links ist leider nur grau.
Dann nimmst du dein T-Net Programm und machst T-Net auf www.ccc.de. Da gibt es auch viele lustige Leute, die sich da unterhalten über die Sendung. Dann ist das nicht so schwierig mit den Frames.
Nee, ich hab da Germany-Net als Provider, glaub darüber geht das nicht.
Also sie haben nur Proxys oder was?
Ja, genau. Ja, gut, dann geht das mit dem T-Net nicht, aber das...
Dann wechsel unbedingt deinen Provider zur nächsten Sendung.
Und gibt's kleine Direkte, Internetadresse, wie ich da jetzt in den Chat reinkomme?
Pass auf, probier's mit chaosradio.ccc.de und dann rollst du die Seite ein bisschen herunter und irgendwo links unten steht Fritz-Webchat und da klickst du drauf und wenn es dann nicht funktioniert, dann ruf uns nicht nochmal an.
Ich hab das alles schon durchgeklickt, bloß ihr könnt mir die komplette URL-Adresse von ihm jetzt im Website geben.
Haben wir ja nun schon ein paar Mal gelesen.
Ja, ist er. www.fritz.de-speakers Das schreibt sich mit E-A.
Also, weiter links eben nur Grausi und nicht den Frame.
Dann leg doch mal auf den grauen Frame und mach Reload Frame oder sowas.
Dann hab ich auch schon alles probiert.
Dann können wir dir nicht helfen.
Dann bleibst du leider außen vor.
Dann würde ich morgen bei Germany Alert anrufen.
Genau, mach sie zur Sau.
Ja, aber allen anderen Seiten klappt das, weil die einst Seite wird noch nicht klappern.
So ein Zensur.
Scheiße.
Steine ziehen.
Kann ich dir nicht helfen?
Kann vielleicht Windows 98 installieren.
Nein, doch nicht.
Ja, krasser.
Ich hab kein DOS Computer. Und dann wollte ich noch fragen, warum bringt ihr nichts über die D-Box?
Na ja, wir kommen nicht dazu. Wir müssen die ganze Zeit Support-Anfragen beantworten.
Von Leuten, die nicht auf den Webchat kommen und so was.
D-Box?
Haben wir doch vorhin gehabt schon.
Ja, wir haben da noch mehr zu erzählen.
Ach so, guck mal.
Das ist ja nicht.
Und was ich noch kurz fragen wollte ist, das nächste Club Discordia da treffen, was ist da für ein Thema?
SSL Workshop unter anderem. Genau, steht übrigens auch alles auf www.cccde.de.
Da kommt aber nicht rauf, wenn Germany nicht.
Doch, da müsstest du draufkommen. Und wenn du damit für Germany nicht raufkommst.
Ich wünsche euch heute einen schönen Abend.
Dir auch.
Ja, ganz kurz noch einen anderen Anrufer.
Hallo? Ich will noch einmal auf die Sachen zurückkommen, die ihr vorhin gesagt habt. Welche Videokarte man nehmen kann, ja, nein. Ihr sagt es vorhin alle. Ich natürlich ein bisschen im Web rumgesurft. Ich habe eine Seite gefunden, da steht, man kann eine ganze Menge Karten nicht nehmen.
Das ist auch richtig. Stani, jetzt sag's einfach.
Naja, du kannst alle Karten, wo der BT848 drauf ist, gut verwenden. Da geht das gleich. Und alle anderen, da musst du die Software umschreiben.
Also du brauchst eine TV-Karte, wo ein BT848-Chip drauf ist. Das ist zum Beispiel diese Hauptauge-Karte, die schon genannt worden ist.
Haupauge, WinTV, Elsa, PCTV, hast du nicht gesehen, all dieses Zeugs. Das sind meistens PCI-Karten und da ist eben dieser Prozessor drauf.
Ja, ich sag mal, Miro-Karten gehen nicht so DC102030 und so.
Das sind ja keine TV-Karten, oder?
Das ist aber eigentlich auch egal, wenn die ein Video-In hat. Also prinzipiell, es geht prinzipiell mit jeder Karte, man muss die Software umschreiben. Das ist halt nicht einfach. Das ist nicht so, dass es nicht ginge. Für die User, die das gleich möchten, die brauchen die Karte mit dem richtigen Stein drauf. Es geht prinzipiell mit jeder Video-In-Karte und das geht auch mit der DC10, DC1, wie sie alle heißen. Nur momentan halt nicht mit der Software, die du aus dem Internet holen kannst. Aber es ist nicht so, dass das Verfahren da nicht funktionieren würde.
Es ist natürlich so, dass es von Chip abhängig ist, ob du Y, Y, V Sampling machen kannst. Das heißt, du hast nicht immer Farbe.
Du hast nicht immer Farbe, das ist richtig. Aber in schwarz-weiß geht es auf jeden Fall.
Dann werde ich mir wohl noch mal den Sourcecode schnappen müssen. Ja, danke euch.
Das ist doch kein Ärger, das ist Fortbildung. Ach, da schnappt man sich mal eben den Sourcecode. Hat da sonst nichts zu tun.
Für Programmierer ist das völlig normal.
Ja, aber Programmierer haben halt ein paar andere Sachen zu tun eigentlich. Programmieren?
Naja, da sind wir doch beim Thema.
Gleich gibt es einen Fritz-Kurz-Info und dann haben wir noch eine halbe Stunde und dann reden wir noch ein bisschen über die T-Box.
Grenzkontrollen vor dem Fußball-WM-Spiel Deutschland-Iran überprüft der Bundesgrenzschutz an allen Übergängen nach Frankreich, Autos und Züge auf gewaltbereite Hooligans. Es gab bereits mehrere Festnahmen und Waffenfunde. Verhandlungserfolg. Der mutmaßliche Doppelmörder von Zenevitz Büch ist offenbar gefasst. Im hessischen Hanau wurde ein Verdächtiger festgenommen. Abstimmung. Der Bundestag hat die Forderung der Bündnisgrüne nach einem Stopp des Transrapidprojekts zurückgewiesen. Die Mehrheit der Abgeordneten sprach sich für den Bau der Magnetschwebebahn aus. Druck. Palästinenser Präsident Arafat hat den Rücktritt der meisten Minister seines Kabinetts angenommen. Das Parlament wirft ihnen Korruption vor. Unfall. Bei einem Schulbusunglück in der Nähe des sächsischen Ortes Bischdorf sind zwölf Kinder verletzt worden. Das Fahrzeug prallte gegen einen Telefonmast, weil der Fahrer ein halbendes Auto übersehen hatte. Fußball bei der Fußball-WM hat Spanien am Abend gegen Bulgarien 6 zu 1 gewonnen. Paraguay siegte über Nigeria 3 zu 1. Beide gelangten eine Runde weiter. Außerdem kamen Frankreich und Dänemark ins Aktenfinale. Frankreich und Dänemark trennten sich 2 zu 1, sowie Saudi-Arabien und Südafrika 2 zu 1. Heute spielen Deutschland gegen Iran, die Niederlande gegen Mexiko, Belgien gegen Südkorea und die USA gegen Jugoslawien.
Was heißt beide? Paraguay und Nicaragua oder Bulgarien und Paraguay?
Bisschen falsch formuliert, eigentlich sind Paraguay und Nigeria weiter. Am Tag in der Frühnebel meist heiter und trocken 23 bis 26 Grad.
Man muss ja ganz dazu sagen, dass Falk das nicht schreibt.
An Neu-Nürnberg Richtung Berlin, Sperrung der Anschlussstelle Niemäck. Wegen Bauarbeiten und eine Umleitung ist ausgeschildert. Und B 109 von Berlin in Richtung Prenzlau. Zwischen Wandlitz und Prenzlau Verkehrsbehinderung durch einen Schwerlasttransport. Vorsicht bei der Annäherung.
Falk Zilke mit dem Fritz, kurz in Form.
Fritz präsentiert. Ein extremer BMX Showwettkampf. Während der BMX-Europameisterschaft vom 10.
Juli in Schweden.
European King of Dirt. Spektakuläre Flüge, schraubige Drehung und fetzige Landung. Samstag, 11. Juli, 15. bis 21 Uhr, am Heinersdorfer Damm in Schweden. European King of Dirt. Die Alternative zur Love Parade mit dem Radio-Fritzen Stefan Michmer auf der Bühne und den BMX-Megastars Syrell aus Frankreich und TJ Levin aus Amerika. European King of Dirt. Präsentiert von Fritz.
Die Alternative zur Love Parade stellt sich die Frage, ob es irgendwas gibt, was der Chaos Computer Club zur Love Parade macht.
Von wegen One World One Future.
Und sie als Motto, um Gottes Willen, wie flach kann man werden.
Wir haben noch keine Diskussion darüber geführt, ob wir einen eigenen Wagen machen und ich glaube, die Diskussion wird verfolgt.
Ich glaube, einen Wagen sollte man natürlich nicht machen.
Wenn man einen Wagen machen sollte, sollte man einen Mobilverkauf durchführen.
Durch aus meiner Idee einen kompletten Sattelschlepper voll mit Computerturmils und Leuten, die hier sich einfach einen abhacken.
Die laufen durch. Weißt du, wie der hinterher aussieht? Den kannst du echt in die Türen führen. Voll scheiße, voll scheiße.
Sind doch auch noch Hippies, oder nicht?
Die trampeln aber alles nieder da. Was soll denn das?
Na ja, ob sie nun auf der Love Parade alles nieder trampeln oder irgendwie.
One World, One Dixie.
Es gibt auch noch andere tolle Partys zur Love Parade auf jeden Fall.
Zum Beispiel?
Nation of Godvana zum Beispiel.
Sagt mir jetzt erstmal nichts.
Kann ich mir schon vorstellen. Also es gibt so einige Partys, die irgendwie nicht in den großen Flyern drinstehen.
Ja es gibt ja einige von euch, die durchaus auf die Musik stehen insofern.
Das will ich doch schon hoffen. Wo ist das?
Godvana?
Nation of Godvana?
Ich kann dir nachher noch mal eine Hotline durchgeben.
Ach, da ist man auch aus Berlin weg, das ist ja gut. Da gibt man nachher noch eine Hotline durch. Gleich noch ein bisschen Infos zur D-Box. Nach den verschiedenen Betriebssystemen wurde hier gefragt im Chat.
Von der D-Box?
Da kam die Frage. Ich hab keine Ahnung von der D-Box. D-Box und verschiedene Betriebssysteme.
Ja, es gibt verschiedene Betriebssysteme für die D-Box. Und zwar gibt es einmal einen ganzen Satz.
Ich kann den noch nicht antworten.
Du versprichst, dass es gut ist.
Lass doch ruhig.
Die Musik, ich finde das alles gut. Also den Programmpunkt, warum Fernsehen dann letztendlich doch scheiße ist, den haben wir dann doch vertagt. Und hier stehen wir noch über die D-Box, ja? Genau.
Und vielleicht auch noch über zwei, drei andere Hacking-Methoden, die es noch so gibt?
Na die kann man ja bei der D-Box gleich mit abhandeln, die treffen alle mehr oder weniger zu. Also die D-Box ist erstmal eine Instanz eines DVB-Receivers. Die ganzen Setup-Boxen, die es da gibt, sind mehr oder weniger identisch, bis auf das Entschlussungsmodul. Da gibt es welche von Irdeto und welche von Habichvergessen. Und in der D-Box steckt ein Irdeto-Modul. Und da gibt es auch wieder eine Chipkarte, wie bei Eurekripp, Videokripp, Premiere und so weiter und so fort. Und das Interessante bei DVB ist, dass das Verschlüsselungsverfahren für alle gleich ist. Und nur die Art und Weise, wie der Session-Key aus der Chipkarte gewonnen wird. Der ist von Decoder zu Decoder verschieben. Aber der Stecker, mit dem man die Karte reinstecken kann, auf der diese Verschüssung stattfindet, ist auch wieder genormt. Das heißt, dass man auch mit der D-Box jedes Programm gucken kann. Vorausgesetzt die Software auf der D-Box. Da sind wir bei der Betriebssystemfrage. Unterstützt das. Es gibt für die D-Box verschiedene Softwares. Einmal die standardmäßige von Nokia bzw. von Beta Research. Da gibt es die Dreambox Software aus den Niederlanden, die Geld kostet theoretisch. Und da gibt es die Software von Dr. Overflow, die auch kostenlos aus dem Internet zu ziehen ist. Theoretisch ist so eine D-Box auch nichts anderes als ein Computer. Da ist also ein Demodulator-Board drin, das ist die 34 Megabit Downstream gewinnt und ein kleiner Prozessor, der das alles managt, ein Hardware Impact Decoder und wie gesagt dieses Krypto Modul. Naja und die D-Box kann man halt ganz genauso angreifen wie alle anderen Modelle. Die Schwachstelle ist die Chipkarte und dass bei allen Chipkarten dasselbe ausgetauscht wird. Man kann also machen, was es schon bei Videokrypt gegeben hat, dass man sozusagen den verschlüsselten Datenstrom aufzeichnet. Bei Videokrypt geht das einfach mit einer Videokassette. Bei der D-Box müssen wir da schon ein bisschen mehr Aufwand treiben. Und dann protokolliert man den Datenstrom zwischen der Chipkarte und der D-Box mit. Man hat also eine Box mit einer funktionierenden Karte, protokolliert das alles mit und dann kann man dieses File aufs Internet tun, kann sich das aus dem Internet downloaden und kann dann mit seinem aufgezeichneten, verschlüsselten Stream und den aufgezeichneten Informationen aus der Chipkarte wieder um den Fernsehen gucken. Das ist zwar in einem späteren Zeitpunkt nicht Echtzeit, aber das geht dann durchaus trotzdem.
Also um es noch mal zusammen zu fassen, der Trick ist, dass man ein Lauscherohr aufmacht zwischen der Karte und dem eigentlichen Decoder. Da während der Sendung eigentlich nichts anderes gemacht wird, als dass der Decoder die Karte nach Sessiongees fragt.
Genau.
Aufgrund von Daten, die über die Leitung kommen. Und wenn man das alles so normal auf dem Videorecorder aufzeichnet?
Ja bei der D-Box geht das nicht. Das funktioniert da ja gar nicht, das muss man dann auf Platte aufzeichnen.
Wie kommt man denn in den digitalen Datenstrom? Kommt man in den Rand?
An den kommt man ran. Man kommt an den... Das ist die eine Möglichkeit, dass man eine Software, die das auf Scasi ausgibt, die andere Möglichkeit ist, dass man die Box aufmacht. Und die Demodulator Platine ist extra und man findet diesen Connector relativ leicht. Im Internet ist dokumentiert, auf welchen Pinsten die Daten anliegen. Dann muss man sich ein bisschen Hardware basteln, schreibt das bei sich auf Platte, kann das dann genauso wieder in die Box einspielen. So kann man es mit seinem DVD-MPEG-2-Decoder auf dem PC sich angucken.
Also man muss im Prinzip an diesem Stein den rohen MPEG-Data Stream, den rohen verschlüsselten MPEG-Data Stream abgreifen, speichern. Parallel dazu noch die Kommunikation des Decoders mit der Chipkarte mitschreiben. Und wenn man es dann abspielt, dann speist man diesen digitalen Datenstream wieder an der gleichen Stelle ein, an der Stelle in der Box. Und hat nun aber nicht eine Chipkarte drin, sondern halt irgendwie, da braucht man auch schon vorher diesen, das sogenannte Season Interface oder Inverse Reader genannt.
Also was wir auch schon vorhin hatten, dann wird die Chipkarte im Prinzip auf dem Rechner simuliert. Was man auch noch machen kann bei allen Verfahren ist, die Kommandos, mit denen die Karten ein- und ausgeschaltet werden, abzufangen. Es gab es auch zuerst für Videocrypte sogenannte Blocker, die man zwischen die Karte und den Decoder steckt und die verhindern, dass die Karte vom Sender abgeschaltet werden kann. Und die dritte Möglichkeit ist auch wieder bei Videocrypte zuerst entdeckt worden, die Attacke nannte sich Phönix, wegen der Asche usw. Das war eine kleine PC Software, wo man einen Chipkarteninterface an sein PC hatte, eine Karte reingeschoben hatte und dann hat der PC das Einschaltkommando für diese Karte selber generiert. Das gab es dann später in Kombinationen, also einen Blocker schrägstrich Phönix, da hat man dann eine alte abgelaufene Skykarte genommen, hat die in dieses Gerät reingeschoben, das alles in den Decoder und konnte dann trotzdem gucken. Und das geht selbstverständlich in der Theorie, mit der D-Box alles auch.
Aber das ist nicht bekannt, wenn man die ein oder ausschaltet.
Das ist so im Detail nicht bekannt. Aber die grundlegende Schwachstelle, nämlich dass in allen Chipkarten der gleiche Key drin sein muss, die gibt es trotzdem immer noch.
Ist doch kein Problem, noch zwölf Minuten in dieser Ausgabe vom Chaos Radio Computer Blumen bei Fritz jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Mehr Infos entweder unter www.fritz.de oder unter chaosradio.ccc.de oder unter www.ccc.de oder einfach mal bei der Auskunft einfach aufrufen, das geht auch. Was natürlich jetzt überhaupt nicht aufgetaucht ist, aber was auch nicht in dieser Sendung gehört hat, vielleicht kurz ein paar Sätze dazu, einmal natürlich Internet im Fernsehen. Da gibt es inzwischen einige Boxen, die das tun. Und überhaupt Kombinationen Internet, Fernsehen. Man versucht GEZ zu bekommen inzwischen, weil man kann ja schließlich übers Internet, also Internet GEZ, so eine Art Internetgebühr, soll bezahlt werden, weil man kann ja inzwischen auch übers Internet Fernsehen gucken, angeblich.
Radio hören zumindest?
Radio hören auch. Es gibt so Geschichten wie WebTV, dass ist dann in den Staaten der Versuch, das Internet auf den Fernseher zu bekommen. Hier läuft das ein bisschen über die Elektronikgroßmärkte, habe ich den einen, warum die bieten solche Geschichten an.
Es ist auch irgendwie immer noch so ein grundlegender Kampf. Es gibt ja jetzt Fernseher, die Internet eingebaut haben. Manche gehen da irgendwie einen ziemlich schrottigen Weg und bauen da irgendwelche Scheißbrowser ein. Das Schlimmste ist irgendwie, es gibt da noch einen Fernseher, wo ein Windows 95 System drin ist, damit zumindest der Browser irgendwie aktuell ist.
Hab ich beim KTV gesehen, der ist richtig teuer.
Ja, wenn man sich so den CT-Test irgendwie anschaut von der letzten Woche, dann weiß man auch, was man davon zu halten hat. Ich glaube, vor drei Wochen war das. Vor einigen Jahren gab es ja schon so diese Idee, dieses tolle Buzzword Interactive Television, so dann irgendwie Oracle und noch so ein paar andere Schwachmaten in Orlando, irgendwie riesige Testszenarien aufgebaut, sinnlos glasfaserverbuddelt, irgendwelche Testgucker angeschaut und die durften dann mit irgendwelchen sterilen Fernbedienungen irgendwie da rumklicken. Also wir haben bei uns im Club auch noch so eine schöne Grafik an der Wand hängen, wie sich die Telekom das mal vorgestellt hat. Das war so eine einfache Schema-Zeichnung, irgendwie da war das so ein Haus und dann ging da irgendwie ein Kabel, ein dünnes Kabel raus und ein dickes Kabel rein und über das dicke Kabel kam halt Fernsehen und über das dünne Kabel konnte man dann irgendwie zwei Funktionen machen. Das eine ist irgendwie Order und das andere war Buy.
Da gibt es so eine schöne Grafik, genau.
Also hervorragend. Also letzten Endes, wir sind davon überzeugt, dass Fernsehen ein Dienstsystem im Internet aufgehen wird. Während es derzeit eher ja noch so aussieht, als ob Internet das ist, was Fernsehen ergänzt. Sicherlich ist das auch nicht falsch für eine Übergangszeit. Also ich denke, dass jetzt erst mal der klassische Fernsehmarkt, wo man sozusagen ein abgeschlossenes Gerät hat, was einen diesen Dienst Fernsehen hochbringt, dass da über kurz oder langen URLs rüberflutschen werden und durch irgendeine Art Rückkanal über Kabel oder eben noch über Telefonleitung wird da Internet mit verknickt. Aber spätestens mit der Einführung von ADSL, diesen neuen Zugangstechnologien, die die Telekom ja derzeit auch kräftig pusht und noch andere haben da Interesse, das zu machen, sind die Bandbreiten da, um auch realistisch brauchbare Videobilder über diese Internetleitung zu übertragen.
Genau, ADSL gibt 1, 5 bis 2 Megabit zum Privatkunden.
Genau, und das ist halt bei den derzeitigen Kompressionsraten, die jetzt schon über Modem erzeugt werden, ja teilweise schon ganz gute Bilder erzeugen, genug Spielraum, um wirklich gut Fernsehen zu übertragen. Also zumindest die Qualität, die wir von VHS kennen oder von dem normalen PAL kennen, wird sicherlich relativ bald problemlos erreicht werden können.
VHS ja, PAL nein.
Ja, das sehe ich auch so.
Also 2 Megabit ist VHS Qualität, aber das was du normalerweise auf dem Fernseher siehst, da brauchst du 6 Megabit für.
Mit Kompression?
Ja, natürlich mit Kompression. Ohne Kompression geht es ja gar nicht.
Das ist nicht toll, aber das reicht.
Du gehst jetzt von MPEG aus.
Du kannst MPEG nicht weiter komprimieren.
Nee, MPEG nicht, aber es gibt euch durchaus noch andere Decoder, die für bestimmte Fälle mit deutlich niedrigeren Video-Raten...
Aber für Geradenbedingungsfall Fernsehen nicht.
Wieso nicht? Ich meine, sicherlich gibt es für die installierte Fernsehtechnologie einen Standard, auf den sie sich auch alle eingespornet haben, der sicherlich seinen Weg machen wird, aber auf den Internetkanten können halt auch andere Kompressionsverfahren irgendwie ihre Wege finden und die sind nicht so gut.
Die MPEG ist das beste Kompressionsverfahren, das es derzeit gibt.
Wir wollen nicht bestreiten, dass irgendjemand irgendwie noch was besseres erfindet, aber das gibt es derzeit nicht. Und wenn wir jetzt schon zwei, drei Jahre reden, dann wird sich das in MPEG 2 abspielen und das ist das beste, was es gibt gerade.
Naja, bei Audio, weiß nicht, ob das jetzt so ohne weiteres zu vergleichen ist, ist es ja auch nicht unbedingt so. Da gibt es ja auch noch spezielle auf niedrige Bandbreiten angepasste Kompressionsverfahren, die halt irgendwie auf Modemgeschwindigkeiten durchaus guten Stereo Sound erzeugen, wo MPEG nicht hinkommt.
Die kommen mit niedriger Bandbreite aus, um wenig schlechteren Sound zu machen, aber sie machen mit der höheren Bandbreite nicht unbedingt wesentlich besseren Sound. Also mit der gleichen, wie jetzt zum Beispiel bei MPEG 1 und R3.
Wie weit kann man denn runtergehen, um Paar zu haben mit MPEG 2 Video?
Also ich denke so 5-6 Megabit pro Sekunde braucht man auf jeden Fall.
Ich denke da brauchen wir auch nicht drüber zu streiten. Es wird 1, 5-2 Megabit zum Endkunden geben und damit wird man VHS Qualität zum Kunden bringen können und nicht mehr. Genauso wird das kommen und genau das wird auch reichen, um das Internet zu einem attraktiven Videomedium zu machen. Und die Telekom wird da Filme anbieten im Prinzip. Nicht nur die Telekom. Ja oder wer auch immer die Telekom wird als erstes diesen Service anbieten. Da gehe ich von aus, die haben die Netze dazu. Die werden mit Dienstleistungsunternehmen ähnlich wie Videotheken, die dann einfach ihre Media Stream Server hinstellen, diese Filme anbieten. Die werden Pay Per View sein, das heißt du bezahlst dafür, dass du einen Film schaust und dann kommt der rüber. Bei Music On Demand haben sie das ja nun auch gerade eingeführt, ist im Feldversuch.
Und genau so bei einer großen Präsentation in Hamburg, lediglich gescheitert, diese Woche.
Das Problem ist, dass es geliefert wird.
Nee, das ist genau das Problem, dass in dem Moment, wo jetzt wirklich 60 Millionen Bundesbürger das haben wollen, dann geht das den Bach runter. Das geht nämlich nicht.
Das wird erstmal ein Individual Service sein, aber ich denke auch, dass die Zeit von diesem... Weißt du, warum du nicht Premiere guckst, obwohl du jetzt einen PC hast, der das irgendwie kann? Weil du einfach, um eine bestimmte Sendung zu sehen, musst du zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt davor sitzen und es dir angucken. Diese ganze, dieses Synchronisieren mit irgendeinem blöden Fernsehprogramm, das ist das, was mich am meisten nervt. Also durchaus, so bei Arte laufen einfach massenhaft Filme, die ich mir unbedingt gerne mal anschauen wollte. Gerade diese Magazin, die sie haben, aber ich sehe sie einfach nicht, weil ich dazu irgendwie Samstag 18 Uhr oder Donnerstag 17 Uhr vorm Fernseher sitzen muss, weil ich einfach in meine Lebensplanung nicht reingehe.
Die Frage ist wirklich, ob du dir irgendwann die Zeit nimmst, dieses Programm anzugucken, wenn du Zeit hast. Also es gibt ja auch Bücher zu jedem Thema und du kannst eigentlich in die Bibliothek gehen und das dann lesen, wann du willst.
Ja gut, die sind nicht aktuell. Das ist ein Problem. Du kriegst also die Bücher, die ich lese, die müssen auch irgendwie letzte Woche gerade rausgekommen sein.
Ja wieso? Du brauchst, weiß ich nicht, für Faust keine aktuelle Ausgabe.
Also Faust kann mir auch nur irgendwo runterladen.
Also das ist ja das Problem.
Ja gut, aber dafür gibt's ja...
Du kannst mir stellen, aber das ist ja was anderes.
Oder du bestellst das oder du gehst in den Buchladen oder du gehst in die Bibliothek. Das Problem ist ein anderes.
Also ich hatte heute das Problem, heute wollte ich einfach mal Zauberflöte. Arie, Königin der Nacht, hätte ich jetzt einfach mal auf einen Klick gebraucht. So gab's nicht. Hätte es das gegeben, hätte ich mir das wahrscheinlich auch sofort gekauft. Vielleicht sogar. Kann ich nicht nur einschätzen.
Das aus dem CCC, vielleicht hätte ich dafür bezahlt.
Vielleicht hätte ich sogar dafür bezahlt.
Es hatte einen Wert in dem Moment für mich.
Nee, ich würde dafür bezahlen, wenn ich damit das Recht erwerbe, das jederzeit per Klick aus dem Netz zu holen. Ich kauf das nicht, wenn das dann auf meiner Festplatte ist. Weil da geht irgendwas schief. Linux, Windows oder wie sie alle heißen, machen irgendeinen Mist und meine 170 Mark Sound auf meiner Festplatte sind Flöten.
Das musst du natürlich mit erwärmen, aber Music On Demand ist sicher noch mal ein anderes Thema.
Ja, das kann das nicht.
So ging es mir halt irgendwie auch mit Arteberichten. Da wird man vor allem auf Sachen hingewiesen, von denen man nichts wusste. Da lief doch letzte Woche der und der Bericht. Und der ist halt noch nicht verfügbar. Aber das ist denke ich die Anwendung, wo es wirklich kommt. Gerade diese Fernsehsender, ihre Sachen.
Ich denke aber, wir werden das nicht so schnell sehen. Das skaliert einfach nicht genug. Die ganzen Leute, die Video-On-Demand-Tests gemacht haben, haben festgestellt, dass die Hardware dafür noch nicht taugt. Das erste, was wir sehen werden, ist Broadcast übers Internet. Und das mit immer mehr und immer mehr Kanälen.
Was heißt, wieso Video-On-Demand? Das muss ja nicht in Echtzeit anschaubar sein. Das darf ja auch runterladen. Hauptsache, es ist überhaupt erst mal verfügbar. Und von den Bandbreiten her auch zu bezahlen.
Und das war es fast. Super schönes Ende.
Kann man auch abstimmen, wer der müdeste ist?
Alle glaube ich ziemlich durch. Man hat da teilweise doch Arbeitstage hinter sich. Obwohl wir eigentlich hier frisch und ausgeruht ankommen müssen. Sehr technische Ausgabe, aber das ist immer unterschiedlich. Im Chaos Radio hier, wie gesagt, jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat, der Computerblumen bei Fritz mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Chaos Radio einmal im Monat. Und mal wird es technischer, mal wird es allgemeiner, mal wird es lustiger, mal wird es ernster. Mal gucken, wie es nächsten Monat wird. Genau, das war es erstmal.
Wenn du eine tolle Party feiern willst, dann ruf in zwei Wochen 440-52-971 an.
440?
52-971.
Vielleicht gibt es Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf.